[Musique]
voir ou revoir votre
programme sur
publicsena.fr pour demain c'est
l'émission qui va à la rencontre des
artisans et des entrepreneurs qui
innovent réinventent ou perpétuent les
traditions de leur territoire des
reportages et des portraits que nous
découvrons et commentons avec un
sénateur ou une sénatrice 1 pays pour
demain en Loire Atlantique avec le
sénateur Renand Dantec présenté par
Rebecca fitousi vendredi à 18h sur
Public
[Musique]
Sénat
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver sur public Scéna pour
votre rendez-vous du mercredi pour les
questions au Gouvernement elle commence
dans moins de 10 minutes maintenant vous
allez pouvoir les suivre en direct et en
intégralité accompagné par les
commentaires de Quentin Calmet dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat et avec toutes les
réactions politiques au micro
d'Alexandre Poussard une séance qui se
déroule 3h à peine après l'hommage aux
Invalides rendu aux victimes française
de l'attaque du 7 octobre 1160 personnes
ont été tuées dont 42 ressortissants
français dans l'attaque terroriste du
Hamas Emmanuel Macron a placé son
discours tout à l'heure sous le signe de
la lutte contre l'antisémitisme on
écoute le président de la République il
était
6h et le Hamas lança par
surprise l'attaque massive et
odieuse le plus grand massacre
antisémite my de notre
siècle et dans les notes de musique d'un
lieu de fête ont éclaté les tambours de
l'enfer et les téléphones de nos enfants
qui jusque-là filmai les joies de leur
vie sont devenus les boîtes noires de
l'horreur
ell nous entront ces
images le ciel livide qui se zèbre de
missile les brigades infernales qui
écument le festival se répandent dans
les plaines puis dans les village
fracasse les portes font irruption dans
les foyers dans les chambres sous les
lits les déflagrations les cris de
massacrons les Juifs les grenades les
hurlements les pleurs puis le silence et
première réaction politique dans cette
émission Alexandre vous êtes avec le
président du groupe écologiste Guillaume
Gontard qui était tout à l'heure à
l'hommage aux Invalides bonjour
Guillaume Gontard bonjour vous étiez
effectivement présent à cet hommage
national aux Invalides c'était
nécessaire ce recueillement de la Nation
pour les victimes françaises du Hamas
oui c'était nécessaire c'était
indispensable d'avoir ce temps ce temps
de de rassemblement euh autour justement
de ces familles des des victimes hélas
trop nombreux ces victimes du terrorisme
du du Hamas du du 7 octobre c'estit
important que je dirais que la nation
soit unie et je trouve que le Président
de la République a eu un un discours
digne à la hauteur en tout cas de cette
de cet événement et que et que je salue
est-ce que vous demandez maintenant un
hommage national aux victimes françaises
dans la bande de Gaza notamment sous les
bombardements israéliens mais pour moi
il a il y a jamais deux poids de mesures
ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre est est
terrible effroyable inexcusable euh mais
ce qui se passe actuellement et c'est
mort cette bande de Gaza qui est
bombardée en permanence ces femmes ces
enfants ces hommes qui meurent et cette
je dirais cette vengeance aveugle n'est
évidemment pas acceptable et on demande
un cesser le feu un cesser le feu
immédiat je sais que il y a des
discussions en cours qu'on pourrait
arriver justement à une trêve j'espère
une trêve longue qui permettra en tout
cas que il y ait de l'aide humanitaire
qui puisse entrer dans la bande de Gaza
mais c'est particulièrement important
effectivement que cette trêve et que
c'est cessé le feu puisse se faire une
dernière question sur cet hommage ce
midi les familles des victimes du Hamas
ne souhaitaient pas la présence d'élus
insoumis alors ils sont venus à cet
hommage national ils ne souhaitaent pas
leur présence notamment à cause de leur
ambigué et dans leur réaction à cette
attaque du 7 octobre est-ce qu'ils
avaient leur place dans cet hommage
c'est pas à moi de répondre enfin je
dirais que ça faut demander à la France
insoumise et aux élus de la France la
France insoumise pour moi pour nous les
écologistes notre ligne a toujours été
très claire dès le premier dès le
premier jour que ça soit sur la question
effectivement de ces événements du 7
octobre dramatique de ce soutien aux
familles des victimes aux otages à cette
libération des otages mais également
d'être très clair et très ferme sur ce
qui se passe actuellement qui est
totalement inacceptable en dehors du
droit international sur la bande de
gazant guillume Gontard dans quelques
minutes vous allez interroger le Premier
ministre sur la crise agricole les
réponses qu'il a apporté à la colère des
agriculteurs et notamment j'imagine sur
la mise en pause du plan écopyo du
gouvernement pour réduire l'usage des
pesticides les écologistes dénonce un
recul écologique or c'est une mise en
posuse seulement pendant 3 semaines
jusqu'au salon de l'agriculture pour
revoir les indicateurs sur les
pesticides est-ce que c'est vraiment un
recul bah c'est évidemment un recul mais
c'est surtout par rapport à cette crise
agricole par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
entendre je suis allé sur de nombreux
barrages je rencontre régulièrement des
agriculteurs la question du revenu on n
absolument pas répondu à cette question
du du revenu à ce à ce rapport de force
entre la grande distribution et le et le
producteur et les agriculteurs alors on
nous parle du plan écofyo de son arrêt
comme si c'était les normes les normes
environnementales qui posaent problème
je rappelle que ces normes c'estes
nécessité en tout cas de réduire les
produits phytosanitaires c'est une
nécessité aussi pour l'agriculture on ne
peut pas de cette manière-là appauvrir
nos sols et puis il y a une question de
santé humaine on a une vraie
problématique sur la question des
produits phytosanitaires il y a donc une
responsabilité du gouvernement au
contraire d'aller plus vite d'aller plus
loin mais ça ça veut dire un
accompagnement un accompagnement très
fort de des agriculteur pour pouvoir
aborder cette transition encore une fois
on a besoin d'un CAP et d'un
accompagnement dernière question sur la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur le
groupe énergétique total énergie et
notamment sur le non respect de ses
engagements climatiques et bien
aujourd'hui le patron total Patrick
pouyanet s'est dit je cite choqué par
cette commission d'enquête et par
l'utilisation de moyens publics pour
enquêter sur une entreprise privée il
rappelle que l'État n'est pas
actionnaire de Total qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez je rappelle que cette
commission d'enquête VI des sénateur
écologiste je je pense effectivement
dans le rapporteur et Yannick jado je
pense que moi je suis choqué que
monsieur pouyané puisse être choqué on
fait notre travail de parlementaire
notre travail de contrôle je rappelle
que Total a fait plus de 20 milliards
d'euros de de de Bénéfic cette année en
augmentation très forte qu'il touche de
l'argent public et donc on est en droit
de se poser des questions sur qu'est-ce
qui est fait de de cet argent je
rappelle que 70 % de ce que de ce que
peut investir au total c'est dans les
hydrocarbures à l'inverse total de euh
de de de l'accord de Paris euh donc on a
on a des vraies questions à se poser par
rapport à ça et donc je pense tout à
fait normal qu'on fasse notre travail
euh de parlementaire tout simplement en
tout cas ça donne le ton de l'audition
de Patrick poyanet qui aura lieu à la
fin de cette commission d'enquête merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup G
merci merci beaucoup Alexandre pour
cette réaction politique tant que
Guillaume Gontard part vers l'hémicycle
l'hémicycle où il doit poser d'ailleurs
l'une des questions et tandis que l'on
voit également et bien chard Larcher le
président du Sénat qui sort du cabinet
de départ on rejoint tout de suite
Quentin Quentin calm qui se trouve dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat quels sont les
grands thèmes qu'on attend cet
après-midi parmi les principaux thèmes
aujourd'hui on note les questions sur la
colère des agriculteurs et la crise qui
a agité la France jusqu'à la semaine
dernière on vient de l'entendre le
président du groupe écologiste Guillaume
Gontard qui va s'adresser à Gabriel Atal
pour dénoncer la baisse des ambitions
environnementales du gouvernement du
côté de la majorité présidentielle on
compte également interroger le
gouvernement sur la sur la loi les lois
et Galim ces questions sur les culture
qui seront les toutes premières de cette
séance qui va commencer dans quelques
minutes au-delà de ce sujet d'actualité
on a retenu d'autres thèmes comme ces
deux question sur le logement alors
qu'on attend toujours la nomination d'un
ministre de plein exercice dans ce
dossier peut dire trois questions aussi
si on compte la question sur les sans
abriis avec une situation critique
330000 personnes sans abri en France 4,2
millions de personnes mal logées selon
la Fondation abépierre 2,6 millions de
ménages qui attendent un logement social
on mentionnera enfin deux autres
questions sur le scandale des EOS en
bouteille le groupe NESTLE qui a reconnu
avoir eu recours à des procédés interdit
pour pour purifier ses eaux minérales en
bouteille voilà pour les grands thèmes
th de cette séance qui comm ence dans
quelques secondes et oui effectivement
la cloche vient de retentir on prend
tout de suite la
direction a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le procès
verbal est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues notre ordre du jour
appelle les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en direct
sur Public Sénat et sur notre site
internet chacun sera attentif au respect
au respect bien sûr des uns et des
autres et au respect du temps de parole
je vais donner immédiatement la parole
au président Guillaume Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier ministre lors de
votre déclaration de politique générale
vous avez décidé de hurler avec avec les
loups en
évoquant lors de je je recommande si
c'est possible monsieur le Premier
ministre lors de votre déclaration de
politique générale vous avez décidé de
hurler avec les loups en évoquant une
écologie de la brutalité nouvelle
stratégie de diversion est estampillé
minseé vous faites ainsi vôre le propos
de ceux qui à droite et à l'extrême
droite n'ont jamais eu la moindre
ambition écologique votre unique
objectif qui n'a rien de populaire et de
préserver coûte que coûte la capacité
des plus aisés à polluer et émettre
trois fois plus de Co que les plus
modestes pourtant le président en
campagne avait déclaré ce quinena sera
écologique ou ne sera pas alors Monsieur
le Premier Ministre quand démarrera le
quinena pour vous
répondre la parole est au Premier
ministre monsieur le Premier
ministre merci Monsieur le merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le Président
Gard nous avons dans cet hémicycle comme
dans le pays des débats qui sont
toujours légitimes pouvons avoir des
visions qui sont opposées des
propositions qui sont différentes et je
crois que c'est ça en démocratie de
pouvoir les confronter mais il y a
certaines choses je l'avoue que je ne
comprends pas
totalement d'abord je ne comprends pas
totalement ou pas du tout même pourquoi
est-ce qu'il vous est aussi impossible
de mettre en avant les progrès que nous
obtenons s'agissant de la défense de la
planète et de
l'environnement je rappelle qu'avant
2017 les émissions de CO2 diminuaient à
un rythme moyenne moyen annuel de 1 %
que dans le premier quinena ça a été 2 %
par an et que l'année dernière sur les 9
premiers mois de l'année seulement c'est
5 % d'émissions de CO2 en moins je ne
comprends pas que vous ne puissiez pas
vous en réjouir vous qui est un groupe
écologiste parce que ce succès ça n'est
pas celui du seul gouvernement ni de la
seule majorité c'est celui des
industriels qui ont changé leur mode de
production c'est celui de nos
agriculteurs qui ont aussi fait des
efforts en matière de conversion c'est
celui de toute une société qui se
mobilise pour défendre la planète ce que
je ne comprends pas davantage c'est
d'avoir entendu et vu des élus
écologistes aller sur les barrages aller
au côté des agriculteurs ces dernières
semaines pendant leur mouvements pour
dire qu'ils épousaient leurs
revendications et qu'ils étaient à leur
côté et les soutenaient et depuis nous
avons trouvé une solution et donné des
perspectives aux agriculteurs en lien
avec eux il y a quelques jours
maintenant critiquer méthodiquement
toutes les solutions qui ont été
trouvées avec nos agricultrices et nos
agriculteurs je ne le comprends
pas je ne le comprends
pas alors vous critiquez la position qui
est la mienne celle de mon gouvernement
dans ma déclaration de politique
générale je vous confirme monsieur le
Président
Gontard que pour nous l'écologie ça ne
peut pas être un facteur d'opposition
entre les ruraux et les urbains entre la
droite et la gauche et je le dis
j'appartiens à un gouvernement de
dépassement politique avec des personnes
d'horizon politique différents non mais
je le dis très sincèrement je le dis
très sincèrement la planète la planète
est trop importante la planète est trop
importante pour qu'elle soit l'otage de
positionnement politicien comme vous
venez de le faire moi je le dis je
reconnais le travail qui a été fait y
compris par des majorités de droite par
le passé par Jean-Louis borlau par
Nathalie cossuscoiset par des ministres
de l'écologie qui se sont engager quels
que soient les majorités pour avancer et
permettre à notre pays d'avancer alors
je vous confirme que nous ne nous
livrerons pas à l'opposition entre les
ruraux et les urbains entre les Français
qui ont besoin de leur voiture pour
aller travailler ou tout simplement pour
vivre et les Français qui peuvent s'en
passer entre les agriculteurs et la
planète je n'accepteraai jamais les
discours qui visent en permanence à
culpabiliser à punir à sanctionner à Bru
is l'écologie à laquelle je crois et
vous devez le respecter aussi c'est une
écologie qui investit qui accompagne qui
soutient parce que je pense qu'on va
plus loin pour la planète plus loin pour
notre pays en suivant cette ligne là
qu'en cherchant à adresser les uns
contre les autres comme vous le
faites monsieur Monsieur le Premier
Ministre Président Monsieur le Premier
monsieur le Premier ministre le clivage
c'est vous c'est c'est ce que je vous
reproche c'est la brutalité de votre
immobilisme Jean-René 50 ans est décédé
dans les Côtes d'Armor après avoir
respiré le sulfure d'hydrogène émis par
les algues vertes lors d'un jogging
brutal Tho 16 ans a subi 54
interventions sous anesthésie générale
pour reconstruire ses systèmes digestifs
et respiratoires une bataille de chaque
instant pour respirer manger et parler
le glyphosate en est le responsable
avéré brutal Marie apicultrce bio dans
le triève voit ses abeilles disparaître
chaque année après année avec un taux de
mortalité de 35 % une tombe les
pesticides en sont la première cause
brutale Marius agriculteur dans l'enjus
ne peut plus consommer l'autre se
rombiné pollué par les solevants brutal
Noémie en Guadeloupe veut un enfant elle
sait cependant que le chord d'conne 30
ans après son interdiction aura un
impact négatif sur le cerveau de son
bébé brutal Lucas 6 mois famille modeste
habite au bord du périphérique a été
hospitalisé en urgence pour une
bioroncotilite sévère d à la pollution
brutale cette brutalité C punitions
aveug cette décroissance du vivant cette
injustice érigé en dogme entre ceux qui
peuvent tout et ceux qui subissent c'est
votre bilan c'est la brutalité et la
brutalité c'est votre
renoncement la parole notre collègue
califé califé pour le group les
républicain vous avez la parole
mon merci Monsieur le
présidentsieur ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
consacré une bonne partie de votre
discours de politique générale à la
santé permettez-moi d'attirer votre
attention aujourd'hui sur la dégradation
des finances de des 32 CHRU et plus
spécialement les établissements publics
de santé cette situation brutale vient
de mettre en péril l'embellie constaté
aujourd'hui sur le plan de
l'attractivité mais aussi de la
fidélisation des personnels soignants
ces difficultés sont liées à plusieurs
facteurs externes bien identifiés sur
lesquelles les établissements n'ont pas
de prise ce déficit est évalué à 1,2
milliards d'euros fin
2023 et il a triplé en un an les
conséquences pour les territoires se
font ressentir avec notamment un
allongement des délais de paiement pour
les fournisseurs locaux et une
fragilisation profonde des OP option
d'investissement des mesures d'urgence
Monsieur le Premier Ministre permettront
sûrement de rectifier cette tendance
négative de même la mise en place d'une
stratégie de financement à long terme
pour continuer à investir innover et
soigner et nécessaire pour nos hôpitaux
Monsieur le Premier Ministre nos
hôpitaux sont ont été un bouclier
sanitaire pendant la crise récente et
resturant le socle de notre système de
soins Monsieur le Premier Ministre
allez-vous activer ces leviers et tous
les leviers nécessaires pour aider nos
établissements de soins à évoluer avec
sérénité
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre du Travail de la
santé et des solidarités Madame
Catherine Vautrin vous avez la parole
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur qualifé
merci monsieur le sénateur d'avoir bien
voulu rappeler toute l'importance que le
gouvernement de Gabriel natal attache au
phénomène de la santé et
particulièrement à l'hôpital la semaine
dernière dans son discours de politique
générale monsieur le Premier ministre a
rappelé combien l'hôpital était notre
joyau hier je recevais le président de
la FHF et sa directrice générale et bien
évidemment avec eux je faisais un tour
d'horizon sur l'ensemble des sujets de
l'hôpital et comme vous j'ai pris
connaissance du courrier adressés par
les élus puisque ce sont les maires qui
sont présidents des conseils de
surveillance des établissements alors je
partage en grande partie ce que vous
avez bien voulu rappeler le rôle de
l'hôpital dans notre pays et
l'implication des personnels et le
retour d'attractivité parce que l'année
23 a été très significative sur plus
d'attractivité la meilleure preuve le
nombre de recrutement notamment
d'infirmières a augmenté ensuite
effectivement nous sommes confrontés à
un sujet financier le gouvernement avait
déjà participé à apporter des réponses C
était le sujet du segéur en matière de
financement avec l'augmentation des
personnels et si vous l'avez évoqué
également le Ségur investissement avec
les travaux de modernisation pour autant
effectivement il y a un sujet en fin
d'année nous n'avons pas encore
totalement la clôture de l'exercice 23
mais nous savons qu'il faut accompagner
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le Premier ministre nous a
accompagné avec nos équipes et dans les
jours qui viennent nous serons en mesure
d'apporter des réponses des réponses sur
les sujets de sous exécution et des
réponses financières qui permettront un
d'assumer les charges y compris
vis-à-vis des fournisseurs locaux mais
qui permettront également de mettre en
œuvre l'investissement pour plus de
modernisation donc plus de conditions de
travail et plus d'accessibilité aux
soins dans notre
pays monsieur califé
califé merci merci madame la ministre
pour cette réponse qui qui me qui me
convient parfaitement vous appliquez ici
une règle que j'aime beaucoup coup les
amours c'est bien mais les preuves
d'amour c'est encore mieux
merci
bien la parole est à notre collègue
Patricia chininget pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates progistes
et
indépendants merci merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
monsieur le ministre nous partageons
tous ici une conviction l'agriculture
est constitutive de notre identité nous
sommes fiers de nos agriculteurs de leur
engagement passionné et nous ne pouvons
être qu'à l'écoute de leurs
revendication légitimes dans mon
département du Aurin j'ai rencontré
comme chacun ici de nombreux
agriculteurs qui m'ont fait part de
leurs difficultés et surtout de leur
sentiment de ne pas être entendus frein
administratif concurrence déloyale et
surtout faiblesse de leur revenus c'est
le bol qu'ils ont exprimé en 30 ans ce
revenu a chuté de 40 % en France bien
loin de refléter les efforts la passion
et le travail qu'ils fournissent au
quotidien avec les lois égalim 1 et 2 le
gouvernement a courageusement porté nous
avons répondu à une partie des
inquiétudes de nos agriculteurs en
inversant la construction du prix mais
l'application de ces lois n'est pas
satisfaisante monsieur le ministre mon
groupe a accueilli avec satisf action
l'annonce du doublement des contrôles
que votre administration va mener mais
les sanctions à prévoir pour ceux qui ne
les respectent pas les règles ne
changeront pas à elle seul la situation
pour nos agriculteurs nous devons
veiller à l'application pérenne des lois
égalim nous le devons à nos agriculteurs
pour améliorer leur quotidien et pour
faire en sorte que leur travail soit
justement reconnu monsieur le ministre
comment renforcer l'application des lois
égalim afin que les négociations
commerciales soient équilibré et que
chacun puisse vivre dignement de son
travail je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle Monsieur Bruno le monsieur
le
président madame la
sénatrice Patricia
chilinger je partage totalement ce que
vous venez de dire sur le revenu des
producteurs c'est évidemment le combat
essentiel je l'ai mené comme ministre de
l'Agriculture pendant 3 ans je le mène
comme ministre d'économie et des
Finances avec le Premier ministre et
avec le ministre de l'Agriculture Marc
fen il y a pas d'agriculture sans paysan
il y a pas de paysan sans revenus décent
et le revenus décent il doit être
garanti par le strict respect des lois
égalim nous avons donc lancé à la fin
des négociations commerciales elles ont
pris fin le 31 janvier un doublement des
contrôles la direction générale la
consommation de la répression des
fraudes sur 1000 contrats concernant 75
des plus gros industriels et les 5
distributeurs sur ces 1000 contrats
124 ne respectent pas pour des raisons
de calendrier notamment les dispositions
de la loi égalim j'ai donc lancé les
injonctions à l'ensemble des
distributeurs et des industriels qui ne
respectent pas les règles ils ont 15
jours pour fournir des explications ou
s'y conformer faute de quoi chacun
encourra de sanction de 5 millions
d'euros par infraction et croyez-moi
nous n'aurons pas la main qui tremble
les sanctions tomberont sur tous les
distributeurs et tous les industriels
qui n'auraient pas respecté strictement
et rigoureusement les dispositions de la
loi égaline deuxième chose ces
dispositions s'appliquent à toutes les
négociations qu'elles aient eu lieu en
France ou qu'elles aent eu lieu par
l'intermédiaire des centrales d'achat
européennes un produit qui est vendu en
France doit respecter toutes les dispos
position de la loigalim même s'il a été
négocié par l'intermédiaire de ces
fameuses centrales d'achat européenne
j'y veillerai aussi et j'ai aussi doublé
les contrôles sur ces centrales d'achat
européennes et sur les négociations qui
ont eu lieu enfin troisième chose sur
laquelle nous veillons particulièrement
c'est la tromperie du consommateur qui
est aussi le vol du producteur quand
vous avez un poulet sur lequel vous avez
un étiquetage avec un drapeau tricolore
c'est une tromperie du consommateur et
c'est un vol du producteur qui lui
s'échine à travailler à cultiver à
produire en France sur le territoire
français avec les normes françaises et
avec les réglementations françaises là
aussi nous avons multiplier les
contrôles les industriels qui s'amusent
à mettre des drapeaux tricolores sur les
produits qui viennent de l'étranger
s'exposent à une sanction qui pourra
aller jusqu'à 15 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires là aussi les sanctions
tomberont et personne ne passera entre
les mailles du
filet madame ch
non donne la par notre collègue Pierre
jeanoch pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre le cor nu mes chers
collègues vous devez comprendre que si
l'Europe est attaquée nous ne viendrons
jamais pour vous aider et vous soutenir
ces propos surprenants sont ceux du
président américain Donald Trump tenu à
Ursula von derlen la présidente de la
Commission européenne en 2020 Thierry
Breton ne pouvait pas inciter avantage
les Européens à bâtir la défense
européenne qu'en nous rappelant ces
paroles une des conditions cineéquanon à
cela est d'avoir une France forte et
capable sur le plan militaire on dit que
Poutine a ressuscité l'OTAN en
envahissant l'Ukraine il est vrai que
deux pays scandinaves ont manifesté leur
souhait de rejoindre l'organisation
après des décennies de désengagement un
effort budgétaire massif s'opère partout
en Europe mais dans quelques mois si
Donald Trump est réélu gagne les
élections que vaudra encore l'Alliance
atlantique au-delà des nouvelles
adhésions nous devons absolument nous
pencher sur nos capacité la question des
munitions est un enjeu crucial de la
guerre de haute intensité chaque jour
les Ukrainiens tirent entre 5 à 8000
obus quand les Russes tirent exactement
le double les États européens se sont
engagés à soutenir l'effort de guerre
ukrainien et a livré à Kiev 1 million
d'obus c'est-à-dire au mieux 6 mois de
munition nous ne tiendrons pas cet
engagement nous espérons tout juste
pouvoir atteindre la moitié et livrer un
peu plus de 500000 obus avant fin mars
pourquoi parce que nous n'en produisons
pas assez mais aussi parce que nous
continuons collectivement d'en exporter
au bénéfice de pays qui ont bien moins
qui en ont bien moins besoin que
l'Ukraine monsieur le ministre il est
grand temps d'intensifier le le soutien
de notre pays à l'Ukraine et de nous
réarmer où en est l'économie de guerre
annoncée par le président Macron merci
pour vous répondre la parole au ministre
des Armées monsieur le corn vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président du
SAT mesdames Messieurs les sénateur
monsieur le le sénateur sur la question
que vous posez sur l'UTAN on aura
d'ailleurs l'occasion d'y revenir dans
le cadre des travaux de la commission
Affaires étrangères et défense puisque
le président Perin à la suite du
président Cambon ont décidé justement de
revenir sur la question de la place de
la France au sein de l'OTAN il y a quand
même une réalité on le voit bien qu'il
nous faut travailler avec les différents
partenaires européens y compris la
Grande-Bretagne par son modèle d' par
lapport de sa dissuision nucléaire
évidemment pour l'ensemble continental
il nous faudra évidemment continuer à
nous réarmer c'est le sens au de
programmation militaire que vous avez
voté sur la question de l'aide à
l'Ukraine et au fond notre économie de
guerre vous le voyez bien on est passé
d'une logique de cession sur les stocks
de nos armées une logique de production
pour évidemment continuer de soutenir
l'armée ukrainienne dans la guerre
qu'elle mène suite à l'agression russe
cette remontée en puissance elle est
indispensable y compris pour nous-même
dans les différents conflits que nous
pouvons connaître elle est indispensable
parce que cette perte de muscle
industriel s'exliqué évidemment pour le
contexte stratégique lié à la fin de la
guerre froide malheureusement aussi
monsieur le sénateur lié aux diminutions
de crédit budgétairees pour les forces
armées pendant pratiquement plus de 15
ans qui ont évidemment conduit à une
perte de commande et donc à une
réorganisation dans le mauvais sens de
notre industrie et si les crédits
augmentent depuis 2017 ça reprend du
temps évidemment de monter en puissance
bon pour répondre précisément à votre
question l'économie de guerre en tout
cas l'a repris de la production par nos
industries est en cours elle profite
très directement à l'Ukraine je pense
qu'il y a un certain nombre de résultats
qui sont là par exemple l'entreprise
Talès où il fallait 24 mois pour
produire un radar désormais il faut 6
mois MBDA les missile Mistral sur la
défense solaire il fallait 24 mois c'est
désormais 15 mois je pense que le
résultat autour du canon César Nexter
est évidemment à saluer 30 mois pour
produire un canon César divisé par 2 15
mois et je viment remercier les équipes
de ces entreprises parce que derrière ce
n'est pas que de l'organisationnel c'est
aussi une augmentation du temps de
travail des 38 des entreprises et des
salariés des ouvriers des ingénieurs qui
sont engagés pour permettre justement de
relever ce défi les munitions évidemment
là aussi les résultats sont là notamment
pour les obus 155 mm maintenant l'enjeu
c'est d'avancer sur ce qui justement a
pris du retard les missiles Aster les
missiles complexes Aster 15 Aster 30 qui
sont évidemment indispensables pour
l'Ukraine dans la protection de son ciel
j'aurai l'occasion d' revenir devant
vous
prochainement monsieur
Rochet merci Monsieur Merci monsieur
ministre pour votre réponse écoutez nous
comptons sur vous pour maintenir
l'effort et continuer à soutenir
l'Ukraine
merci la parole est à notre collègue Hed
l pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre Béchu
chers collègues en 2017 le chef d'État
chef de l'État s'était engagé à ce que
plusieurs personnes ne dorment dans la
rue 6 ans plus tard les derniers
chiffres de la Fondation abpierre sont à
larmant et font état de 330000 sans abri
parmi eux une proportion croissante de
femmes et d'enfants il est primordial de
comprendre les parcours de vie qui
conduisent ces personnes à se retrouver
sans domicile fixe et les raisons
peuvent être multiples la perte d'un
emploi des difficultés financières des
problèmes de santé mental des ruptures
familiales ou encore des situations de
violence domestique ces personnes
vulnérable se trouent exposé à
l'insécurité de la rue et à des
conditions de vie très précaires les
centres gements sont surplés les
services sociaux sont débordés et les
programmes d'aide sont insuffisants
environ une personne sur deux qui
contactent le 115 ne se voit proposer
aucune solution d'hébergement ayant
moi-même pris l'initiative d'appeler le
115 en quête d'une solution pour une
personne en grandeulté je n'ai
malheureusement obtenu aucune
proposition concrète cette situation
souligne les lacunes de notre système
actuel il est du devoir de l'État de
trouver des solutions et de mobiliser
les ressources nécessaires pour résoudre
cette crise sociale grandissante
nous devons augmenter de manière
significative le nombre d'hébergements
d'urgence et d'envisager de
réquisitionner les logements vacants
afin de fournir une solution d'urgence
et de temp et temporaire pour les
sans-abris et prévenir les situations
d'extrême vulnérabilité il est
primordial de coordonner les actions des
différentses acteurs impliqués tels que
les services sociaux les associations
caritatives et les collectivités locales
qui se trouvent souvent seules sur le
terrain monsieur le ministre lors du
discours de politique générale du
Premier ministre aucune mention n'a été
faite à cette problématique majeure ce
qui soulève des interrogations
j'aimerais donc obtenir des informations
concernant les mesures spécifiques que
le Gouvernement compte prendre pour
remédier à cette situation quels sont
les projets en cours avenir visant
augmenter le nombre de places dans les
hébergements d'urgence que comptez-vous
faire pour renforcer les programmes
d'aide au sans-abri et améliorer
améliorer l'accès au services sociaux
merci monsieur le ministre de vos
réponses pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre la cohésion des
territoires de la transition écologique
monsieur béch avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur
lawedge votre question elle fait
effectivement écho à ce rapport du
malogement présenté par la Fondation
abépierre la semaine dernière à
l'occasion du 70e anniversaire de
l'appel lancé précisément en
1954 les chiffres on les connaît on a eu
l'occasion de les rappeler ils sont
présentés dans ce rapport 330000 non pas
sans abri mais mal logé ou sans domicile
et en face
l'État a mis en place des moyens qui
sont sans précédent 3 milliards d'euros
avec deux types de dispositif 203000
places d'urgence un record et 114000
places dans le cadre du dispositif
national d'accueil quand on additionne
ces deux chiffres et qu'on les rapproche
des 330000 on voit qu'on a un écart
d'une dizaine de milliers de places et
si le premier ministre n'en a pas parlé
c'est parce que tout début du mois de
janvier le 8 janvier Patrice verrit
avait annoncé le déblocage au nom du
gouvernement d'une nouvelle enveloppe de
120 millions d'euros représentant
l'équivalent d'une dizaine de milliers
de places
mais monsieur le sénateur laette je n'ai
pas entendu dans votre question la
volonté d'avoir des réponses
arithmétiques ce que vous avez convoqué
ce sont bien des situations humaines
c'est à la fois le désarroi de
travailleurs sociaux pour lesquels ça
n'est pas satisfaisant de se retrouver
sans solution et puis ces femmes ces
hommes ces histoires d'herance ces
difficultés et avec au-delà des
statistiques une attente qui n'est pas
seulement un toit pour une nuit mais qui
est d'avoir des solutions le plan
logement d'abord ce sont 550000
logements qui ont été réalisés au cours
de ces dernières années plus de la
moitié ont été attribués à des gens qui
étaient sans domicile devant nous il
faut qu'on continue avec le tissu
d'acteur à agir mais il faut aussi en
parallèle que nous regardions en face le
fait que face à cette situation pour
accueillir mieux nous devons sans doute
accueillir moins
et c'est aussi la suite à la fois de
décisions qui ont été prises de textes
qui ont été votés et de ce que nous
aurons à mettre en œuvre dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois la parole est à notre collègue
adelsian pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre B depuis 2017 les cris
multiplie dans notre pays gilets jaunes
retraite les émeutes urbaines le monde
agricole il y a quelques jours mais
actuellement une crise a atteint un
point de NS retour c'est celle du
logement et en particulier du logement
social 70 ans après l'appel de la baé
piierre vous en parliez votre
responsabilité est immense et vos
réponses ne sont aujourd'hui pas la
hauteur pas la hauteur au moment où le
rapport annuel de la Fondation dont vous
parliez a présenté des chiffres
dramatiques 12 millions de personnes
fragilisé par la crise du logement 4
millions de personnes mal ou non logé 1
million de personnes dans un habitat
digne et plus de 300000 personnes sans
domicile en France pas à la hauteur
également au moment où nous n'avons
toujours pas de ministre du Logement
peut-être prochainement et pas à la
hauteur enfin quand le Premier ministre
dans son discours de politique générale
aura à peine consacré 3 minutes à ce
sujet extrêmement important pour nous
annoncer avec une consternation partagé
par l'ensemble des acteurs concernés les
maires des grandes villes de France qui
vous ont fait une lettre ouverte à ce
sujet les associations de locataires de
solidarité les spécialistes de
l'immobilier consternation donc avec
cette proposition de modifier le Calc et
ru pour intégrer les logements libres
intermédiaires tour de passp statistique
qui va casser le thermomètre de la
mixité sociale et aura un impact quasi
nul voire négatif sur la production de
logements sociaux dans notre pays ma
question est simple comptez-vous
abandonner cette proposition enfin
mettre en œuvre une politique
volontariste ambitieuse en matière de
logement dans notre
pays pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur sénateur
zan votre question n'est pas non plus
tout à fait à la hauteur du moment
elle ne l'est pas parce que à vous
entendre
elle ne l'est pas parce qu'à vous
entendre à vous entendre et la
démocratie c'est le respect il y aura
une crise qui fera PRS notre pays on
serait sur un îot de déstabilisation et
de difficulté quand dans tous les pays
aujourd'hui sous l'ffet de la hausse des
taux d'intérêt et de l'augmentation des
coûts de construction les matériaux ont
conduit et ont entraîné une baisse de la
production en Allemagne où vos amis sont
en responsabilité la baisse des mises en
genantier est comparable à celle de la
France en Chine aux États-Unis partout
alors dire qu' nous aurions un problème
français sincèrement c'est passer à côté
d'une forme de responsabilité de vous
pointez du doigt le fait que le
gouvernement ne répondrait pas en étant
à la hauteur les mesures que nous avons
prises si elles n'ont pas permis
d'enrayer la crise elles ont permis de
la juguler dans un domaine un où le
recul est moins important que dans les
autres c'est précisément sur sur le
logement social la baisse de
construction sur logement social est
deux fois moins importante et ce qui a
le moins reculé c'est le trait social
pourquoi parce qu'avec le plafonnement
du taux livr à 3 % et avec les
programmes de rachat qui ont été décidés
par CDC habitat pour le compte du
gouvernement et par Action Logement nous
avons limité ensuite à vous entendre il
y aurait une forme de ségrégation
sociale qui considérerrait que tout ce
qui n'est pas
UE n'est pas digne d'intérêt la moitié
des attribution l'année dernière de lli
se sont faites au bénéfice de gens qui
sont sous les plafonds des lls en région
parisienne sur les 3000 pardon sur les
4500 attributions le revenu moyen des
couples était de 3600 € pour un couple
avec deux enfants à ce niveau-là on
n'est pas dans les classes supérieures
on a le droit de se retrouver avec une
solution la volonté de construire des
parcours résidentiels de regarder
comment nous soutenons des MRES
bâtisseurs et nous recontinuons et nous
reconstituons un cont um d'offre c'est
la solution à laquelle on doit s'atteler
tous ensemble au-delà des anathèmes
au-delà des chiffres en mesurant que le
problème est plus large et que pour le
résoudre il faut l'état il faut les
collectivités locales et il faut les
[Applaudissements]
banques monsieur le ministre pas de gêne
pas de réponse à l'ambiqué mais surtout
pas de dénis c'est un point extrêmement
important puisque depuis le début de ce
quinquena et le précédent je le rappelle
depuis 2017 baisse des aides au
locataires aux bailleurs sociaux à
l'accession à la propriété production de
logements sociaux en chute libre divisé
par de entre 2023 et 2024 pas de soutien
financier de l'État ni d'objectif de
construction les réponses existent
monsieur le ministre relance de la
production de logement sociaux accession
à la propriété ces réponses elles sont
urgentes elles vous ont été soumises par
tous les acteurs du secteur que vous
avez convoqué lors du Conseil national
de la refondation logement nous vous le
demandons Monsieur le Ministre enfin il
faut prendre à balcore le logement cœur
de la cohésion sociale de notre pays je
vous
remercie
la
parole est à notre collègue Pascal
Savoldelli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyens et écologiste canak
merci merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
avec respect et avec sincérité je vais
vous exprimer un coup de
colère un coup de colère parce que je
suis dans un département où nous avons
dépassé les 100000 demandeurs de
logement un coup de colère parce que 12
millions de personnes fragilisées par la
crise du logement c'est 12 millions de
sinistrés oui c'est une bombe sociale à
retardement la vérité c'est que dès 2017
vos politiques n'ont été qu'un jaaccuse
du logement social pour libérer toute
contrainte le marché privé baisse des
aPL dès l'élection du président Macron
ponction de 1,3 milliards d'euros dans
les caisses des bailleurs sociaux
loiélan pour obliger à vendre des
logements sociaux à la découpe et faire
disparaître les petits bailleurs la loi
casbariant berger pour faciliter les
expulsions et nous voilà désormais à
démelé la loi de solidarité et de
renouvellement urbain monsieur le
ministre le bilan est dramatique il n'y
a plus de politique publique du logement
en France pour les acteurs du secteur de
nombreux emplois sont menacés et la
majorité des habitants de notre pays est
livrée elle-même face à la à la
spéculation ma question est simple
monsieur le ministre 56 % d'augmentation
des loyers dans le parc privé Stop ou
Encore 2000 enfants à la rue stop ou
encore à quand l'état d'urgence du
logement pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur le
ministre monsieur le sénateur
salveelli avec respect avec dignité je
vais répondre à votre crit de colère
dont je mesure totalement la sincérité
mais la même sincérité elle doit
conduire à regarder les choses en face
nous n'avons pas une solution du
logement nous avons des solutions on a
3,5 millions de logements vacants dans
notre pays pas forcément aux endroits où
il y a les tensions on a des endroits
qui continuent de construire queles que
soient les couleurs politiques et on a
des endroits où la pression des
habitants sur le fait de ne pas avoir de
voisins conduit à une diminution du
nombre des permis de construire qui a
anticiper une partie des difficultés que
nous connaissons celui qui vous parle il
a 36,94 % de logement sociale dans sa
ville le rythme de construction de ces
dernières années a Angé il a été plus
important que celui des villes de Nantes
et de Ren c'est bien la preuve que tout
ne dépend pas que des circonstances
nationales en revanche par rapport à ce
que vous êtes en train de dire oui il
faut une forme d'union sacré autour des
élus autour du fait d'aller simplifier
une partie des normes qui explique une
partie de ses coûts autour du fait de se
demander comment on rend du pouvoir
d'achat immobilier à des classes
moyennes parce que nous avons un
entassement des demandes de logement qui
sont lié à la difficulté d'accès à la
propriété et c'est à la fois le sens du
choc d'offre que le que le premier
ministre a pu annoncer et des travaux
que nous lançons au sein du ministère de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires avec Bruno Le
Maire pour expertiser en particulier le
crédit Infiné le crédit hypothécaire qui
sont des dispositifs qui dans des pays
voisins ont permis d'aller soulager ou
relancer une partie de ces difficultés
le logement social faut qu'on garde le
sujet en face au congrès de l'USH 1,2
milliards d'annonces de tien le vote ici
dans cet hémicycle d'un dispositif de
deuxème vie parce que nous avons aussi
des logements qui ne sont pas sur le
marché parce qu'ils nécessit des travaux
de rénovation énergétique que nous
devons conduire donc
oui à l'union sacrée oui à la
mobilisation de crédit sans précédent
c'est le cas pour l'hébergement
d'urgence oui à la relance avec
l'ensemble des acteurs décembre plus 22
% de mise en chantier plus 7 % de dépôts
de permis de construire la stabilisation
des taux du livra et de l'inflation nous
laisse penser que nous sommes précis
dans la situation nous pouvons avec un
choc d'offre inverser les choses parce
que nous croyons la nécessité d'un
logement pour tous d'une France avec
l'espir des propriétaire pour ce qu'ils
peuvent et de logements sociaux dans des
taux suffisants partout sur le
territoire
merci Monsieur
SAV faute de ministre du Logement je
vais m'adresser à vous Monsieur le
Premier Ministre
oui nous appons à déclarer l'état agence
nationale du logement sur 5 axes
moratoire sur les expulsions encadrement
des prix du foncier plan pour les primau
accédant relève du niveau de production
et réquisition national des logements
vides pour cela encore faudrait-il avoir
une ou un ministre du Logement Monsieur
le Premier Ministre l'abbé Pierre disait
gouverner c'est d'abord loger son peuple
vous êtes le chef du gouvernement alors
maintenant vraiment
gouverner
la parole est au président Laurent
Laffond pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous avez
déclaré la semaine dernière que pour
préserver l'audiovisuel public il faut
rassembler les forces en un pôle
puissant vos propos rappellent les
travaux d'un de vos prédécesseurs Franck
rester qui avait présenté en Conseil des
ministres un un projet loi autorisant la
création d' hing pour chapauter tous les
acteurs de l'audiovisuel public
malheureusement la crise de la covid a
arrêté à l'Assemblée national les débats
sur ce texte et vos deux prédécesseurs
Roseline Bachelot puisim abdoumanac
n'ont pas souhaité reprendre ce projet
faisant preuve d'une certaine crainte
pour ne pas dire étant un peu timoré sur
le sujet des coopérations dans le
secteur de l'audiovisuel public le Sénat
qui préconise cette holding depuis 2015
a voté en juin dernier un une
proposition de loi que j'avais déposé
qui était rapportée par jean-rimmond
Hugonis autorisant enfin cette holding
c'est pour nous le plus sûr moyen de
renforcer l'audio public l'audiovisuel
public dans un secteur doublement
concurrencié concurrencé par les acteurs
du net mais aussi concurrencé par les
plateformes américaines il est
nécessaire en effet de rendre pérennes
et définitive ces coopérations à travers
une gouvernance commune et des actions
concrètes dans les fonctions support
mais aussi dans l'investissement dans
les nouvelles technologies en
particulier l'intelligence artificielle
alors madame la ministre pour renforcer
ces coopérations il y a trois
possibilités la première c'est les
convention d'objectifs et de moyens tels
que l'État le met en œuvre depuis
plusieurs années et dont on sait
maintenant qu'elles sont inefficaces la
deuxième c'est la holding dont je vient
de parler et la troisième c'est la
fusion entre chacune des entités du
secteur de l' visuel public madame la
ministre ma question est simple elle est
double quel est le scénario que vous
privilégiez pour se créer ce pôle
puissant que vous appelez et quel est
votre
calendrier répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre de la Culture madame
rachidti vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président la fond je crois
que la réponse est dans votre question
je m'associe à tous vos arguments
d'abord c'est vrai et je l'ai dit et je
le disais d'ailleurs bien avant ma
nomination comme ministre de la Culture
nous avons besoin d'un audiovisuel
public puissant ça c'est une réalité je
sais aussi monsieur le Président puisque
nous avons eu quelques échanges que nous
partageons plusieurs convictions sur ce
sujet alors l'adoption et vous l'avez
rappelé en juin dernier de votre
proposition de loi relative à la réforme
de l'audiovisuel public et la
souveraineté audiovisuelle évidemment en
témoigne évidemment je m'appuierai sur
ces travaux alors bien sûr il y a votre
texte mais aussi il y a de nombreux
travaux réaliser d'ailleurs je je les ai
consulté avant mes interventions par qui
ont été réalisé par le Sénat comme le
rapport des sénateurs carucci et Hugonet
publié en
2022 excellent rapport kucci
Hugonet et le rapport de 2015 des
excellents tout aussi excellents
sénateurs gatolin et l leu
alors alors risque du vous l'avez vous
les avez vous l'avez rappelé sur les
enjeux et cet environnement très
perturbé avec tous ces bouleversements
technologiques l'uniformisation des
contenus par les grandes plateformes
internationales la désinformation sur
les réseaux l'irruption de
l'intelligence artificielle tous ces
enjeux-l évidemment vous les aviez
intégrés alors c'est vrai il ne faut pas
se dérober et il faut pouvoir répondre à
ces en jeux cruciaux alors moi je plaide
pour un audiovisuel public qui rassemble
toutes ses forces ça correspond
évidemment à votre texte je sais que ces
attentes il y a des attentes très fortes
sur ces sujets alors moi j'avancerai en
concertation évidemment avec vous je
m'appuierai je le dis ici je l'avais pas
préciser auparavant je m'appuierai sur
votre texte et sur votre PPL monsieur le
Président la fond et euh également avec
vous les sénateurs mais aussi sans
exclure aucun autre intervenant et
notamment vos collègues députés et les
grands sujets pareil nous les aborderons
de manière très précise et euh de
manière assumée quels sont-ils notamment
le finance
du service public de l'audiovisuel mais
j'avais déjà donné mes convictions bien
avant et je raccontrerai je vous l'ai
dit les dirigeants de des sociétés très
bientôt et nous nous reverrons
évidemment pour lancer ses travaux
ensemble et je vous le redis on ne se
dérobera
pas
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Jeanrond Hugonet pour le groupe les
républicains président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
Culture il y a quelques jours vous avez
indiqué votre souhait d'incarner une
culture populaire et ouverte sur tous
les Français vous avez même ajouté je
cite ma vie s'est construite avec
l'audiovisuel public dès lors pourquoi
ne pas commencer votre action par
l'audiovisuel qui attend une réforme
depuis si longtemps en effet la loi de
86 relative à l'ensemble de
l'audiovisuel est à bout de souffle
l'absence de pluralisme et de réforme du
service public menace le consensus
nationale sur la nécessité de lui
accorder plus de financement la
réglementation de la production enrichie
des fonds d'investissement américains
qui ont mis la main sur de nombreux
producteurs français et j'en passe
est-ce que la déburaucratisation promise
par Monsieur le Premier Ministre a
vocation à s'arrêter aux portes de
l'audiovisuel français est-ce que la
maîtrise de la dépense publique est
condamnée à ne pas concerner
l'audiovisuel public der dernière adepte
du quoi qu'il en coûte est-ce que le
principe de libre entreprise est obligé
de ne pas s'appliquer à nos chaînes
privé entravé par des réglementations
surabondantes quiignorent les
plateformes américaines en un mot madame
la ministre est-ce que les proposition
constante du Sénat depuis 2015 sont
vooué à être toujours salués mais
rarement appliqué par des locataires de
la rue de Valois d'autant plus applaudi
lors de leur départ que leur bilan aura
été minuscule la proposition de loi de
mon collègue et ami le président Laurent
Laffond dont je fus le rapporteur adopté
par le Sénat il y a quelques mois
constitue une base solide pour avancer
pouvez vous nous précisez vos intentions
et surtout votre calendrier madame la
ministre dans ce domaine pour vous
répondre la parole est Madame la
Ministre de la Culture madame vous avez
la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Hugonet j'allais dire je vais
reprendre la réponse que je viens de
faire au président
Lafond je vais faire simple je vais
reprendre la PPL vous avez raison ça
c'est la première chose dès que possible
alors vous avez raison parfois on
applaudit les bilans maigres puis
parfois on napplaudit pas quand le bilan
est réel j'en sais quelque chose alors
je vous le dis évidemment je vous
consulterai évidemment je travaillerai
avec vous évidemment c'est une non c'est
pas non c'est pas ça c'est une réalité
malheureusement c'est une réalité
simplement le sujet est trop sérieux
vous avez raison pour le différer encore
une fois les enjeux sont lourds il faut
effectivement un audiovisuel public
puissant et très fort et sans réforme je
crois que effectivement les contrats
d'objectif je trouve que c'est une
mauvaise ça n'a pas si bien marché que
ça je le je le reconnais et sur le
calendrier B on va démarrer ensemble on
va essayer évidemment il faut consulter
tous les acteurs pour qu'on puisse mais
je crois aussi que du côté de
l'audiovisuel public ils ont aussi
avancé sur cette volonté aussi de réfme
de réforme sur le financement mais aussi
sur la gouvernance notamment sur les
coopérations renforcées et j'is dire
même sur la gouvernance unique et sur la
fusion notamment des réseaux de
proximité qui a un peu commencé mais qui
n'a pas été abouti et donc nous allons
la poursuivre pour la mettre en œuvre
sur la gouvernance sur le financement ce
sont des enjeux cruciaux que nous
mettrons en œuvre ensemble je vous
remerci monsieur
Hugonet merci monsieur le Président nous
avons entendu madame la ministre votre
volonté d'ouvrir le débat quant à
l'avenir de l'audiovisuel il y a urgence
car nous devons nous pencher dès la fin
de l'année sur l'avenir de son
financement notamment autant le dire
clairement les conditions ne sont pas
réunies aujourd'hui pour accorder un
blancin sous la forme d'une modification
de la loi organique seul une réforme
d'envergure garantissant le pluralisme
et réformant la gouvernance pourrait
justifier une telle évolution nous
sommes à votre disposition ici au Sénat
vous avez souligné l'excellence des
travaux du Sénat dans ce domaine nous
sommes
disponibles
merci la parole est à notreègue
al pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
et
républicain merci merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
la France n'est pas assez riche de ses
enfants pour en négliger un seul telle
était la première phrase du premier
texte signé par le général de Gaulle à
la Libération entre 2017 et 2019 pas de
ministre chargé de la protection de
l'enfance et nous attendons depuis des
semaines la composition du gouvernement
il a fallu une succession de drame pour
que le Président de la République se
rende compte que la protection de
l'enfance exiger un un pilotage
politique en 2019 de la même façon vous
avez attendu Monsieur le Premier
Ministre qu'un autre drame humain se
déroule dans mon département le puids de
dô avec le suicide d'une enfant d'à
peine 15 ans placé pour prendre enfin
les décrets d'application d'une loi
votée il y a 2 ans à la hâte hier soir
dont l'encre est encore peu sèche et
dont les contours nous sont encore
inconnus face à l'inertie de votre
gouvernement les inquiétudes et colères
légitimes se multipli et vous devez les
entendre on Renou demain un ministre de
l'enfance et de la protection de
l'enfant France doter des moyens
financiers pour initier enfin un plan
Marchal de la protection de l'enfance
plus qu'urgent avec tous les acteurs
concernés et des invisibiliser ces
350000 enfants placés et les
professionnels qui les accompagnent sans
relâche
merci pour vous répondre la parole au
ministre du Travail de la santé des
solidarités madame Vautrin vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Canales merci madame
la sénatrice de rappeler la mémoire de
cette jeune fille aujourd'hui qui est
précisément le 2e anniversaire de la loi
taquet alors c'est vrai qu'il restait
des décrets mais que le premier ministre
arrivé il y a 3 semaines a signé ce
décret et nous savons et nous savons
qu'il était important nous savons que ce
décret était tout à fait important
puisque pour être très concrète ce
décret est celui qui interdit le
placement d'enfants dans des
établissements commerciaux et ça je
crois que c'est important de de le dire
parce que ces enfants qui sont confiés à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sont celles et
ceux qui ont le plus besoin d'être
accompagné et l'esprit de la loi taquet
parce que il faut le rappeler c'était
précisément de favoriser la parole de
ces enfants que ces enfants soient
écoutés beaucoup en ont parlé cette
majorité l'a fait alors aujourd'hui nous
apportons effectivement des réponses
c'est toujours trop long quand on
s'occupe des enfants mais je voudrais
dire que un c'est fait et deuxièmement
je voudrais souligner le travail que
nous menons avec les départements parce
que ce sont les départements qui au
quotidiens sont au côté des
professionnels des enfants et ces
départements ne manquent pas de nous
interpeller parce que nous devons
regarder la situation avec lucidité
après le covid les violences
intrafamiliales ont augmenté elles
appellent des réponses c'est le sens de
notre engagement c'est aussi le sens du
projet de loi de finan pour 2024 qui a
permis un accompagnement financier donc
regardons les progrès mesurons le chemin
à parcourir et mobilisons-nous
ensemble madame
Canales alors il vous reste encore 24
heures pour décider si oui ou non il y
aura un ministère de l'enfance et de la
protection de l'enfance la protection de
l'enfance devait être l'enjeu du
quinquena depuis rien rien de lors de la
de votre déclaration de politique
générale Monsieur le Premier Ministre
rien pour les 350000 enfants placés dont
10000 bébés certains atteint du syndrome
de l'hospitalisme rien pour la santé
mentale de ces enfants qui perdraient 20
ans d'espérance de vie et font 37 fois
plus de dépression et de tentative de
suicide rien sur la reconnaissance de
l'utilité sociale des professions de la
protection de l'enfance rien pour les
départements en première ligne et qui
font face à un resserrement de leurs
finances le propre de la puissance et de
protéger disait pourtant bless Pascal
votre gouvernement semble toujours plus
pront à réprimer qu'à protéger j'en veux
pour preuve que les décrets
d'application relative au code de la
justice pénale des mineurs ont eux été
pris en 3 mois quand il a F attendre 2
ans pour la de l'enfance combien encore
de DRAM avant de tenir la promesse de
faire de la protection de l'enfance une
priorité et un vrai
ministère la parole est à notre collègue
George naturel pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre omie des finances
et de la souveraineté
industrielle monsieur le ministre la
filière nickel en Nouvelle-Calédonie
traverse actuellement une crise d'une
rare gravité les trois usines
métallurgiques de knns de laasln et du
Sud connaissent depuis plusieurs mois
des difficultés majeures et sont au bord
du dépôt de bilan plusieurs milliers
d'emplois directs et indirects sont en
cause et de très nombreuses familles
calédonienne vivent dans l'angoisse de
Lain de lendemain particulièrement
difficile la fermeture de l'usine de KNS
qui est aujourd'hui la plus menacée avec
environ 1300 emplois directs et qui
vaudrait proportionnellement la
fermeture dans l'Hexagone d'un site
industriel de plus de 300000 emplois
lors de votre visite sur place fin
novembre dernier vous avez proposé sous
réserve de trois conditions aux
industriels et aux collectivités
calédoniennes un Pact nickel pour sauver
chacune des usines en fixant à fin
janvier 2024 la date limite de sa
signature cette échéance est aujourd'hui
dépassée et aucun Pact na encore été
signé alors que la situation ne cesse de
s'aggraver monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer précisément
quel est à ce jour l'état des
négociations de ce pacte nickel pour
chacune des des usines avez-vous obtenu
de la part des actionnaires Eramet pour
la SLN Glencore pour knns et Trafigura
pour l'usine du Sud les engagements que
vous demandez avez-vous obtenu l'accord
de tous les calédonien pour que les
ressources minières soient mieux
valorisées quand allez-nous allez-vous
annoncer pour chacune des usines le
montant et la date du déblocage des
prérelais de l'État et enfin quand
allez-vous annoncer les modalités et le
calendrier du soutien de l'État pour
moderniser la production électrique et
réduire son coût pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
Monsieur le Président Monsieur monsieur
le sénateur naturel je
partage totalement votre diagnostic sur
l'état de la filière nickel en
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui est confronté à
la fois à une compétition nouvelle de la
part de l'Indonésie de la Corée du Sud
de la Chine qui produisent à des coûts
bien inférieurs et un effondrement du
cours du nickel les deux mettent les
trois usines celles du Sud celle de
numea et celle du Nord en grande
difficulté je me suis rendu sur place
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur géralan
quelques semaines pour faire le point
avec l'ensemble des acteurs les élus et
les industriels j'ai dit à quel point je
croyais dans l'avenir de la filière
nickel en Nouvelle-Calédonie le nickel
fait partie de l'avenir économique de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais pour que nous
puissions ouvrir des perspectives il y a
trois conditions que je rappelle la
première c'est effectivement conclure ce
pacte nickel avec l'ensemble des élus
locaux pour mieux exploiter la
ressources minières donner de la
visibilité sur cette exploitation et
permettre l'exploitation des min qui ne
sont pas utilisé parce que ça fait de la
trésorerie pour les industries elles en
ont bien besoin ce pacte nickel la
négociation progresse j'ai bon espoir
que nous puissions parvenir à une
signature définitive sous quelques
semaines la deuxième condition c'est que
l'État s'engage sur la rénovation des
réseaux électriques le président de la
République a pris des engagements je
suis chargé de les mettre en œuvre nous
engagerons les investissements
nécessaires pour moderniser le réseau
énergétique calédonien mais il y a une
troisème condition est essentiel il y a
pas d'usine sans industriel et donc s'il
n'y a pas d'industriel pour opérer les
usines cela ne peut pas marcher pour la
seule usine du Nord KNS j'ai proposé 100
millions d'euros de près de l'État 45
millions d'euros d'aide immédiate 65
million d'euros de soutien sous une
autre forme financière soit près de 200
millions d'euros de soutien pour une
seule usine donc l'État a fait tout ce
qu'il devait faire pour l'usine KNS du
Nord il a fait le maximum
maintenant c'est au actionnaires
c'estàdire la province Nord et glenc de
prendre le
responsabilité naturel vous avez 6
secondes merci en tout cas on attend
avec impatience le résultat de ces
négociation parce que les Calédoniens
ont des aujourd'hui des soucis
particuliers
merci la parole
est pour groupe de l'Union centre
général merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre messieurs
et mesdames les ministres chers
collègues en ce début d'année deux
actualités viennent d'éclabousser et
j'emploie ce terme à dessin le monde des
eaux minérales en France la première est
d'ordre sanitaire puisque c'est une
étude américaine qui déclare que il y
aurait 100 fois plus de nanoparticules
dans l'eau minérale que ce qu'on
estimait au auparavant donc des
nanoparticules qui circulent dans le
sang et qui vont atteindre les organes
et qui vont aller jusque voilà dans
notre cerveau par un petit peu partout
la deuxième est d'ordre économique et
politique c'est pour ça que je m'adresse
à monsieur le ministre Bruno Le Maire
parce que deux médias ont annoncé la
semaine dernière qu'en fait des grands
groupes qui produisent des eaux
minérales et bien utiliser des
traitements qui n'étaient pas autorisés
auparavant pour les EAU DE source or
vous avez autorisé par des arrêtés
préfectoraux ces traitements qui
permettaient que l'eau soit consommable
en quelque sorte mais peut-on considérer
dès lors que ce sont des eau de source
telles qu'elles sont vendues ensuite
vous avez aussi diligenté une étude à
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales mais jusqu'à ce jour nous
n'avons pas eu l'ensemble des
conclusions que nous disent ces
conclusions parce que finalement cette
eau minérale a été vendue
100 fois plus cher que l'eau du robinet
alors que ce n'était qu'une simple e du
robinet puisqu'elle subissait les mêmes
traitements que l'eau du robiné alors
Monsieur le Ministre comment avez-vous
pu accepter ce cette tromperie du
consommateur dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure parce que la tromperie du
consommateur elle ne peut pas être à
géométrie variable et là finalement on a
fait payer à tous les consommateurs le
prix d'une eau du robinet en
bouteilleieur ministéconomie s Bruno le
ma vous avez parfaitement raison madame
la sénatrice il n'est pas question qu'il
y ait de tromperie de
consommateurs pas question qu'il y ait
de manquement à la réglementation donc
lorsque les informations nous sont
remonter les agences régionales de santé
ont saisi le procureur de la République
pour risque de manquement à la
réglementation et trom pris du
consommateur une minérale doit respecter
un certain nombre de procédures un
certain nombre de règles vous les avez
rappelé donc il est indispensable que le
consommateur ne soit pas floué et que
ces règles soient respecté l'agence
régionale de santé les agences
régionales de santé d'ailleurs parce que
il y a plusieurs territoires qui ont été
concernés ont saisit au titre de
l'article 40 le procureur de la
République une enquête judiciaire a été
ouverte et la direction générale de la
consommation de la répression des
fraudes apporte son soutien à cette
enquête pour examiner si oui ou non je
n'ai évidemment pas la réponse les
industriels ont respecté ou non les
réglementations européennes donc
attendons la fin de l'enquête de justice
c'est l'enquête de justice qui
déterminera si les industriels concernés
ont oui ou non respecté les
réglementations en vigueur mais il va de
soi que sil n'y avait pas de respect la
réglementation là aussi les sanctions
nécessaires s'appliqueraient madame
douan
oui finalement l'autre source n'est pas
généreuse par nature elle est coûteuse
par
forfaiture
la parole est à notre collègue Anne chin
Larcher pour le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
sous le feu des médias la loi visant à
lutter contre la maltraitance animale et
conforter le lien entre les animaux et
les hommes a été promulgué le 30
novembre 2021 Loir écrite à 85 % au
Sénat devenu coutumier du fait cette loi
impacte entre autres les animaleries les
cirques parcs zoologiques parc
aquatiques ces professionnels sont
talentueux passionnés soucieux du
bien-être des animaux qu'ils hébergent
soignent et étudient depuis 2021 les
textes réglementaires concernant les
parcs aquatiques accueillant les
mammifères marins ne sont toujours pas
signés promenés de secrétaire d'État en
secrétaire d'État à la faveur des
remanements ministériels ces parcs n'ont
pas de ligne clair sur le cadre appliqu
à leurs activités et de ce fait aucune
assurance qu'elle soit pérenne ce n'est
pas l'esprit de la loi qui a été votée
le coup prê tombera le 1er décembre 2026
c'est-à-dire demain d'ici là ils devront
avoir investi pour être en conformité à
la loi monsieur le ministre ce que vous
imposez à ces professionnels est
inacceptable pouv pouvez-vous nous dire
quand enfin les arrêtés concernant les
conditions d'hébergement les contours
des programmes scientifiqu
et les démonstration public des
résultats des recherches seront
signé pour vous répondre la parole au
ministre de l'Agriculture monsieur F
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice charché vous êtes
très mob très mobilisé pardon sur cette
question vous avez beaucoup participé au
travaux de cette loi sur pour lutter
contre le la maltraitance animale je
répondrai sur la question des parcs que
vous évoquez mais vous dire que d'abord
un certain nombre de décrets ont été
pris sur les sujets qui étaient autres
je pense au sujet de la vente en ligne
sur lequel le décret a été pris en le
1er juillet 2023 le décret aussi qui a
été publié sur le certificat
d'engagement et de connaissance qui doit
être demandé à des gens qui sont
détenteurs d'un animal ou qui font
l'acquisition d'un animal de compagnie
qui et puis troisème décret sur la
formation des détenteurs d'animaux ou en
particulier de ceux qui sont en charge
de refuge et qui recueille des animaux
de compagnie nous avons aussi mis des
moyens importants sur la question des
refuge c'est plus de 30 millions d'euros
qui sont qui sont déployés et puis la
dernière question que vous posez enfin
la question principale que vous posez
elle pose elle relève du registre ceci
étant du ministre de la transition
écologique qui ne pouvait pas être
présent pour la fin de votre question la
question c'est de déployer et de donner
des signaux au détenteurs de ses pas
pour savoir dans quel cadre ils vont
être faits la question qui est posée est
celle de la du délai le délai c'est dans
les semaines ou les au plus tard dans un
ou de mois de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse leur donner les éléments de
clarification réglementaire pour qu'ils
puissent se préparer à la sortie dans le
cadre de la loi telle qu'elle avait été
prévue l'esprit et la lettre de la loi
tel qu'ils avaient été prévu madame
charcher et vous voyez monsieur le
ministre je suis désolée mais vous
n'êtes pas le bon ministre je
m'adressais au ministre Béchu chargé de
la transition écologique ça fait des
années ça fait des années que vous
baladez ces ces professionnels en vérité
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe il se passe que
il faudrait que vous disiez d'ailleurs à
votre administration qu'elle arrête de
prêter le flan aux associations
animalistes qui répondent à une
idéologie W et qui font en sorte de
déconstruire ce qui a façonné la France
alors ici au Sénat on peut vous dire que
nous sommes à côté de ces professionnels
qui sont notre patrimoine ils font la
fierté de la France et au Sénat nous
veillerons à ce que la France reste la
France
bravo la parole est à notre collègue
Hervé Gillet pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste
républicain merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre madame la
ministre rétention d'information auprès
de la Commission européenne
dissimulation fraude aux consommateurs
non respect de la loi vaste tromperie
voilà les faits qui sont reprochés au
gouvernement suite aux révélations de
Radio France et du journal Le Monde fin
janvier cette enquête nous informe qu'un
rendez-vous s'est tenu entre nestley
Waters et le cabinet de Madame panier
runaché alors ministre chargé de
l'industrie en
2021 à la suite de de cette réunion un
rapport de Ligas a été remis au
gouvernement en
2022 ce rapport serait accablant il n'a
jamais été rendu public depuis 2022 le
gouvernement a donc eu connaissance des
pratiques frauduleuses de certains
grands groupes industriels utilisant des
traitements non conformes pour
commercialiser leurs eau de sources et
minéral ceci à priori sans informer la
justice ni les consommateurs sur
initiative de mon collègue Alexandre
wizil nous avons alerté madame la
ministre dès le 31 janvier afin de lever
les doutes sur ce dossier nous sommes
donc en attente avec impatience de la
réponse de Madame la Ministre alors
madame est-ce que vous confirmez les
accusations contenues dans le rapport
d'enquête pourquoi n'avez-vous pas rendu
publ le rapport de liigas allez-vous
désormais le faire votre gouvernement
a-t-il informé la Commission européenne
comme vous en aviez
l'obligation monsieur le ministre de
l'économie
Monsieur le Maire pour
répondre c'est monsieur qui répond et
pas madame monsieur le sénateur mais je
vous ferai la la même réponse que tout à
l'heure il y a une enquête judiciaire
qui est en cours les agences régionales
de santé ont saisi par l'article 40 le
procureur de la République cette enquête
elle doit déterminer si oui ou non les
industriels de l'agroalimentaire je
partage totalement votre avis sur la
gravité des faits qui sont reprochés
Puil s'agit de savoir si oui ou non ces
industriels ont respecté les
réglementations au titre des eaux
minérales ou si les procédés qu'ils ont
employés font que ça n'était pas des
eaux minérales ou ça ne répondait pas au
caher des charges fixé pour les eaux
minérales donc c'est effectivement en
matière de tromppris du consommateur
comm le rappelait madame la Catrice tout
à l'heure un enjeu majeur l'enquête
judiciaire est ouverte la justice a été
saisie par les ARS au titre de l'article
40 la direction générale la consommation
la répression des fraudes va apporter
son expertise pour déterminer la
conformité ou non de ce qui a été décidé
par les industriel et la justice rendra
sa décision dans les semaines ou dans
les mois qui viennent donc laissons la
justice mener son enquête jusqu'au bout
je pense qu'elle est la seule à même
désormais à pour apporter des réponses à
vos questions monsieur
gilet je vous remercie monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre il faut
observer dans cette affaire la
chronologie des faits et vous étiez
informé le gouvernement était informé
bien longtemps déjà de cette situation
les ARS se sont mobilisés beaucoup plus
tardivement et quand on analysera le
pourquoi elles se sont mobilisées c'est
pas forcément sur votre injonction donc
ça c'est de sont d'élément importants
donc ce sont des faits qui sont
particulièrement dommageables pour notre
démocratie à la fois en terme de
conivance avec des intérêts privés et
surtout en terme de confiance vis-à-vis
des citoyens et de leur gouvernant il
vous crée quelque part les conditions
d'une société de défiance et de
suspicion pire ce type de comportement
peut alimenter les théories du complot
si vous souhaitez clarifier la situation
vous ne pourrez que soutenir la création
d'une commission d'enquête parlementaire
sur le sujet nous jugerons donc sur les
actes la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Micheline Jacques pour le Gret
républicain vous avez la
parole ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Intérieur et des outres m monsieur
le ministre notre groupe est
profondément préoccupé par la situation
de chaos dans laquelle vit Mayot et sur
laquelle nos collègues Maoris vous
alertent régulièrement du reste la crise
de l'eau récemment très médiatisée C en
réalité ajoutée à l'insécurité la
pauvreté l'insalubrité l'immigration
galopante une crise économique et
sociale profonde aux difficultés liées
aux infrastructures
sous-dimensionnées la population excédée
paralise ma une nouvelle fois pour
protester contre l'insécurité cette
situation insurrectionnelle n'est pas
plus acceptable à maotte qu'ailleurs
dans notre République rétablir
durablement la sécurité et l'autorité de
l'État ce doit être la priorité des
priorités l'immigration incontrôlée est
à l'origine de la pression démographique
il n'est l'équivalent d'une classe par
jour à la maternité il faut durcir les
règles d'immigration et d'acquisition de
la nationalité en vigueur à
à Mayotte certes et tarir la source de
sa principale difficulté mais on ne peut
plus se contenter de mesures d'urgence
qui permettent en effet d'apaiser un
temps les tensions on voit bien que
l'île a besoin d'une vision pour adapter
efficacement et structurellement
l'action de l'État et des collectivités
locales à sa réalité et que sans moyen
l'État ne peut pas s'appliquer
efficacement un projet de loi pour un
développement accéléré de Mayotte avait
été annoncé en 2021 nous sommes en 2024
et le désespoir s'empare de la
population aussi
égard au caractère multidimensionnel de
la crise monsieur le ministre êtes-vous
en mesure de nous annoncer un plan ou
une loi de programmation pour
Mayotte pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur et les arè
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
darin monsieur le Président du du Sénat
mesames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la ce vous avez parfaitement
raison Mayotte connaît des difficultés
très importantes du fait de
l'immigration du fait de la sécurité du
fait des questions économique et social
mais aussi des transports et des
infrastructures dans des conditions
évidemment d'égalité avec le territoire
depuis que le Président Chirac je
voudrais vous le rappeler a décidé de
faire Maillotte un département et il
nous appartient désormais de pouvoir
tenir l'engagement du président de la
République Jair dans des conditions
évidemment très difficile mais vous
connaissez mon engagement profond pour
Mayotte et pour aider archipel à pouvoir
mieux vivre mieux vivre d'abord contre
l'immigration irrégulière c'est le cas
depuis l'opération bouchou c'est le cas
aussi avec la construction du deème
Centre de Rétention Administrative c'est
le cas avec la loi immigration qui
dispose de désormais de moyens
extrêmement importants pour lutter
contre l'immigration irréguli à Mayotte
mais ce qui se passe en ce moment à
Mayotte ce n'est pas simplement de
l'immigration qui viendrait des Comores
ou de Madagascar mais de l'Afrique des
grands lacs du fait de l'islamisme
galopant dans ces territoire particulier
et à Cavani le camp de d'migration que
connaî maotte et qui a fait exploser si
je dire une colère qui était déjà
évidemment très sourde j'ai pris des
mesures sans précédent d'évacuation d'un
terrain qui appartient au conseil
départemental et pour la première fois
de rapatriement en hexagone de personnes
qui étaient reconnu comme réfugié par
l'asile français deuxièmement le Premier
ministre a annoncé dans son discours de
politique générale un projet de loi
Mayotte qui sera donc présenté très
prochainement au Conseil des ministres
et qui prévoit sur les questions
économiques sociales de transport
d'infrastructure un changement radical
pour en effet faire de maotte un
département ce qui pose des questions
aussi de cotisation et de prestation et
qui doiv être la même que tout
territoire national enfin il faut un
changement constitutionnel nous
règlerons pas les questions migratoires
à maotte s'il n'y a pas un changement
radical dans la Constitution qui
s'applique à sur droit du sol et droit
du sang le président de la République on
a ouvert l'augure je propose d'
travailler ensemble avec le
Sénat
[Applaudissements]
madame emble des outr mes a besoin d'un
projet ambitieux car la situation est
aussi le résultat d'une gestion Paracou
et à trop court terme je suis persuadé
que l'on P plus cher à long terme et à
tout point de vue ce que l'on repousse
d'année en année à maotte le
gouvernement doit donc s'attaquer au
cause profonde au premier rang desquels
l'immigration
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Brigitte de pour le groupe de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste Président mes chers collègues
ma question est adressée au ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
monsieur séjourné tout le monde se
souvient du vol mh17 abattu en Ukraine
en 2014 par un missile sol air tiré par
les forces prorusses du donbas aucun
survivant parmi les 283 passagers depuis
le 1er février 2024 Pékin met en danger
la sécurité aérienne dans le dé3 de
Taïwan un vol Air France passe par ce
couloir aérien l'administration de
l'aviation civile chinoise a décidé
unilatéralement d'une modification de
ces itinéraires de vol dans le couloir
aérien m503 qui viennent désormais
frôler la frontière aérienne officieuse
entre Taïwan et la Chine l'objectif de
Pékin est clair harceler les défenses
aériennes de Taïwan et de se servir du
passage d'avion civil pour camoufler des
manœuvres militaires Taïwan condamne
cette décision et pote les conséquences
néfastes en terme de sécurité des
passagers internationaux dont nos
ressortissants en provenance et à
destination de shanghï la révocation de
l'accord aérien conclu en 2015 entre les
deux rives du détroit de Taïwan
constitue un coup de force et porte
atteinte au statut co malgré une
résolution du Sénat votée en 2021 mai
2021 et les différents appels de
nombreux pays comme la France la Chine
empêche la démocratie taïwanaise de
siéger à l'Organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale la question que je
vous pose monsieur j'y associe monsieur
le ministre à mon collègue Olivier cad
que va faire la France pour amener la
Chine à revenir à l'accord aérien conclu
avec Taïwan en 2015 et sécuriser ainsi
nos ressortissants je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères Monsieur S
journé merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice permettez-moi
d'abord peut-être un un commentaire sur
l'actualité que que vous venez de
décrire nous sommes évidemment très
préoccupé par les tensions croissantes
dans le détroit de Taïwan et pour être
très clair sur notre position et la
remettre ici de manière transparente
avec vous toute modification unilatérale
du statut nous sommes opposés ainsi que
tout usage de la force et de la
coerition nous y sommes opposés
également pour être très clair la
position de la France est très constante
de ce point de vue-là c'est un message
que la France porte d'ailleurs à haut
niveau auprès des des autorités
chinoises en les encourageant d'ailleurs
à privilégier le dialogue et éviter
toute escalade en
France la France est attachée à la paix
à la sécurité de la région cette
position d'ailleurs se traduit par le
passage régulier de notre marine
nationale dans les eaux internationales
du détro nous marquons ainsi en faisant
passer la Marine nationale notre
attachement à la liberté de navig ation
et de survol conformément d'ailleurs au
au droits international que nous
revendiquons dans cette zone s'agissant
de
l'Organisation de l'aviation civile
puisque c'était votre
question nous regardons de près avec nos
partenaires le développement lié à
Taïwan et nous veillons dans ce cadre à
ce que son absence ne compromette pas la
sécurité aérienne évidemment mais plus
largement madame la sénatrice vous le
savez nous avons également une position
constante sur de ce point de vue nous
soutenons également dans le respect de
la politique d'une seule Chine la
participation de Taiwan aux travaux
d'organisation internationale mais il
faut que les statuts le permettent et
que ce soit d'intérêt collectif et donc
cas par cas les organisations donneront
un avis que la France suivra à partir du
moment où nous sommes dans le cadre du
droit international merci Madame DEA
oui rapidement monsieur le ministre je
voudrais personne n'est dupe ici la
Chine irritée par les résultats de la
présidentielle à Taïwan cherche
désormais à instrumentaliser l'aviation
civile par des considérations politiques
et militaires je répète la France doit
appeler à l'ouverture de négociations
pour sauvegarder le statut Coo dans le
détroit de taiïwan fondé sur la paix la
sécurité dans le respect mutuel et celui
des règles de droit je vous remercie
merci merci monsieur Premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
en avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement les
prochaines auront lieu le 14 février
2024 à 15h je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour la
proposition de loi visant à interdire
les dispositifs électroniques de
vapotage à usage unique la séance est
[Musique]
suspendue
voilà pour cette séance de question
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité avec de très
nombreux thèmes on a parlé logement
agriculture audiovisuelle publique dans
l'hémicycle cet après-midi on va
débriefer tout ça sur ce plateau mais
d'abord place aux réactions salle des
conférences et d'abord le président du
groupe Union centriste au micro
d'Alexandre Poussard Hervé Marseille la
suite du remanement du gouvernement se
fait attendre on a par exemple parlé cet
après-midi de la crise du logement une
véritable urgence ça fait un mois qu'il
n'y a pas de ministre du Logement il est
trop tardé ce remaniement complet du
gouvernement
écoutez le président et le Premier
ministre décide du temps c'est vrai que
maintenant il faudrait quand même que on
sache qui est en charge de quoi parce
que les les ministres qui ont un champ
d'action comme Monsieur Béchu logement
environnement transport il faut qu'il
soit secondé donc effectivement on
attend avec impatience la suite est-ce
qu'il pourrait y avoir des sénateurs
centristes dans le gouvernement RV
Marseille je n'en sais rien je n'ai pas
été consulté sur le sujet mes collègues
me disent qu'ils ne le sont pas non plus
donc W and vous vous attendez et vous ne
seriez pas contre si jamais c'était le
cas un sénateur centriste qui entrerait
au gouvernement de toute façon encore
une fois si un sénateur répond
favorablement c'est son
choix comme d'autres l'ont fait
auparavant dans d'autres groupes donc on
verra mais personnellement j'ai pas été
consulté et à ma connaissance dans le
groupe non plus il y a de l'attente
également autour de l'agenda
parlementaire on a eu la déclaration de
politique générale de Gabriel Atal avec
beaucoup d'annonces mais concernant les
textes de loi qui vont arriver au
gouvernement il y a pas il y a pas
vraiment de de grand texte un petit peu
flottant vous avez peur que le Parlement
soit contourné avec ce nouveau
gouvernement je pense que le
gouvernement
euh a une certaine méfiance du Parlement
il y a pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale donc c'est dangereux de se
promener avec des textes à
l'Assemblée au Sénat c'est moins
dangereux on travaille les textes on en
a produit retraite immigration mais
d'ici le mois de juin je suis pas sûr
qu'on voit beaucoup de textes celui qui
est prévu c'est
l'IVG on va voir ce que ça va donner
alors vous dites ce n'est pas dangereux
pour le gouvernement de débattre de
texte au Sénat alors sur la lois
immigration ça a été un petit peu
compliquéin la majorité du Sénat a quand
même modifié ass considérablement et
bien cette loi avant que les mesures
soient retoquées et d'ailleurs les
centristes font une proposition de loi
pour que ces mesures retoqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel soit
réintroduite dans une nouvelle loi
immigration fin de non recevoir des
députés de la majorité présidentielle
notamment des députés Renaissance à quoi
ça sert de de remettre sur la table un
débat sur l'immigration écoutez oui j'ai
j'ai noté que le président du du groupe
Renaissance Sylvain Maillard s'était
exprimé sur le sujet on verra le moment
venu nous nous avons repris euh les
articles que le Conseil constitutionnel
avait jugé comme étant des cavaliers
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'avaient pas leur
place dans le dans la loi donc on a
refait une proposition de loi on verra
le moment venu s'il a lieu de de la
sortir et de la discuter je pense que à
un moment ou un autre faudra compléter
le texte déjà voté une question sur et
bien peut-être le principal texte des
semaines à venir euh dans cette agenda
parlementaire et bien à l'introduction
de du droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution ça a été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat il y a une
incertitude hein sur l'issue du vote le
président du Sénat Jard Larcher est
contre tout comme le président du groupe
LR Breno rotillot euh ce serait et bien
un piège euh dans lequel tomberaient les
sénateurs s'il rejetaient cette réforme
non je crois que chacun aura à
s'exprimer euh en conscience
euh je partage le le point de vue du
président Larcher à titre personnel euh
je l'ai déjà dit et j'ai déjà voté de
cette façon-là la Constitution à mes
yeux n'est
pas n'a pas vocation à être un un
catalogue de droits sociétaux ceci étant
dit mon groupe votera comme il le
souhaite et Dominique Verrien qui est
rapporteur sur le sujet elle est
favorable et elle essaie de convaincre
ses collègues de voter on verra le
moment venu je pense qu'au final à la à
l'Assemblée ça a été voté au Sénat ça
finira par la aussi ce sera voté et il y
aura il y aura un accord sur une
rédaction commune pour aller en en
congrès à versaill et on verra on verra
ça passe en commission je crois la
semaine prochaine et on verra s'il y a
des propositions et s'il y a des sujets
d'amélioration parce qu'on rappelle que
les deux chambres doivent voter cette
réforme constitutionnelle dans les mêmes
termes pour qu'après et bien elle soit
adoptée en congrès à versaill par et
bien les 3/5è des voix du Parlement
merci beaucoup RV Marseille pour votre
réaction voilà pour cette réaction de
d'Hervé Marseille et puis autre réaction
à votre micro Alexandre celle de
Catherine vutterin ministre du Travail
de la santé des solidarités pour nous
présenter notamment sa feuille de route
à ce ministère bonjour Catherine
Vautrain bonjour on va parler de la
partie travail de votre portefeuille
ministériel le Premier ministre Gabriel
Attal a la semaine dernière évoqué son
objectif de désmicardiser la France
concrètement comment on fait pour lutter
contre ce phénomène de bas salairire de
tassement de bas salairire dans notre
pays on continue à à baisser les charges
sociales sur ces sur ces bass alairtes
alors vous l'avez compris le Premier
ministre l'a expliqué la semaine
dernière le sujet c'est que 18 % de nos
concitoyens vivent autour du SMIC le
SMIG a augmenté de 13,5i % depuis 2021
il y a toutes celles et ceux qui sont
juste au-dessus et ceuxlà n'ont pas vu
leurs revenus augmentés de la même
manière et ils ont aujourd'hui un
sentiment qui est finalement que ils
gagnent toujours trop quand il faut être
aidé et pas assez quand il s'agit de ne
pas compter et donc l'idée et c'est ce
sur quoi nous travaillons actuellement
avec un un budget qui a été annoncé par
le Premier ministre d'une somme de 2
milliards d'euros de regarder comment
nous pouvons effectivement procéder à
des allègements de charge de façon à
permettre que le revenu de celles et
ceux qui travaillent qui assument leur
vie puissent effectivement augmenter sur
finalement le reste pour remplir le
frigo si je devais le faire extrêmement
rapidement parce que c'est cela qui
compte permettre d'avoir un petit peu
plus de pouvoir d'achat donc il y a
l'enveloppe de 2 milliards d'euros et
maintenant à voir à voir comment nous
pouvons travailler sur le sujet c'est ce
que son train de faire l'ensemble de nos
équipes pour répondre dans les meilleurs
délis à nos concitoyens parce que ce
qu'ils attendent bien évidemment ce sont
des choses qui changent concrètement
alors pour bien comprendre votre feuille
de route sur le travail quand est-ce
qu'il y aura un texte de loi sur la
question du travail et puis qu'est-ce
que vous attendez des négociations
actuelles entre les partenaires sociaux
sur ce sujet est-ce que vous voulez et
bien vous avez certaines attentes dans
cette négociation alors nous sommes au
Sénat et donc bien évidemment je redis à
Public Sénat toute l'importance que
j'accorde à la loi pour autant vous le
savez en matière de droit du travail il
y a une tradition franç qui est celle du
dialogue social donc au mois de novembre
dernier il y a ce qu'on appelle une
lettre de cadrage en d'autres termes une
lettre d'objectif qui a été adresser aux
partenaires sociaux pour qu'ils
travaillent ensemble sur l'emploi des
seniors par exemple sur le comp le
compte épargt universel le CET par exle
U et bien l'idée c'est qu'il travaill
sur ces sujets ensemble ils doivent nous
remettre des propositions dès lors
qu'ils sont d'accord fin mars s'ils sont
d'accord sur ces propositions à ce
moment-là nous les transposerons si
d'aventure il n'y avait pas de d'accord
à ce moment-là le gouvernement aurait à
reprendre la main et à transposer pour
être parfaitement limpide je dois
rappeler que le premier ministre a dit
lors du discours de politique générale
que nous suivions avec attention
l'évolution également du marché du
travail car les conditions qui ont
précéder finalement la rédaction de
cette lettre cadre on était au tout
début de l'automne ne sont pas celles
que nous connaissons en février 24 c'est
la raison pour laquelle en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation notamment de
l'Unedic nous pourrions peut-être être
conduits à adresser une autre lettre de
cadrage mais dans tous les cas il y a
évidemment le respect du dialogue social
donc il pourrait y avoir une nouvelle
réforme de l'assurance chômage pour
équilibrer les compte on pourrait être
conduit à travailler une lre de cadrage
tout ça est au conditionnel et dépend de
l'évolution des comptes de l'Unedic
dernière question sur le chômage on a
aussi appris la volonté du gouvernement
pour les chômeurs en fin de droit de
supprimer laallocation de solidarité
spécifique qui donnait droit à des
trimeste de retraite et de remplacer
cela par le RSA pour les chômeurs en fin
de droit c'est quoi l'idée c'est encore
de de durcir les conditions pour les
demand l'idée c'est que la meilleure la
meilleure émancipation c'est le travail
c'est donc d'accompagner nos concitoyens
vers le travail pour se faire l'idéal
c'est effectivement l'expérimentation
qui a été faite avec France travail qui
va rencontrer nos concitoyens les plus
éloignés qui les aident à régler les
difficultés qui sont les leurs qui les
forment et qui ensuite leur permett
d'entrer dans le
travail il y a dans notre pays des
postes qui ne sont pas pourvu
aujourd'hui les amener vers ces postes
notamment est tout à fait important très
concrètement cela veut dire qu'à la la
fin de ce mois nous allons augmenter le
nombre de territoires sur lequel France
travaille travaille aujourd'hui il y
avait 18 expérimentations nous allons
passer à 47 d'ici la fin du mois donc
vous selon vous vous ne durcissez pas
les conditions des demandeur d'EMP som
là pour un demandeur d'emploi ce qu'il
cherche à retourner dans l'emploi notre
objectif c'est de l'accompagner à aller
vers l'emploi c'est la meilleure
émancipation possible pour lui merci
beaucoup Cathrine vin d'être venue au
micro de Public Sénat merci merci
beaucoup Alexandre pour cette nouvelle
réaction place tout de suite au débrief
de cette séance de question au
gouvernement pour cela j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir quatre invités sur ce
plateau Laurence Rossignol bonjour
bonjour vous êtes signénatrice
socialiste du valde Marne
vice-présidente de la délégation au
droits des femmes également sur ce
plateau Laurence Garnier bonjour
sinatrice les républicains de la Loire
Atlantique à côté de vous François
patria bonjour le président du groupe
des sénateurs Renaissance le groupe RDP
sénateur de la Côte d'Or et enfin Thomas
Dosu bonjourour vous êtes sénateur
écologiste du rô et vice-président de la
commission des finances on va parler
ensemble des thématiqu elles ont été
nombreuses he qui ont marqué cette
séance de questions au gouvernement et
encore plusieurs questions aujourd'hui
et bien sur la crise agricole pour en
parler on va rejoindre tout de suite
Quentin Quentin calm dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat vous avez tout suivi tout entendu
il a notamment été question des galimes
cet après-midi dans l'émicycle Quentin
oui tout à fait Tam on a eu donc deux
questions en ouverture de séance sur
cette crise qui a touché la France
jusqu'à vendredi dernier on a vu d'abord
cet échange tendu entre le président du
groupe écologiste Guillaume G tard sur
la question des ambitions écologiques du
gouvernement face à Gabriel Attal et le
Premier ministre on retient également
donc vous le disiez cette prise de
parole de Bruno Le Maire qui a plaidé en
faveur de davantage de contrôle pour que
la loi égalim soit bien appliquée
notamment avec le doublement des agents
de la de la DGCCRF à la répression des
fraudes plus de 10000 contrôles sont
réalisés cette année y compris donc sur
des produits vendus par des centrale
d'achat européenne et en dehors de
France ça c'est ce qu'a dit le ministre
il a également en parlé des fraude à
l'étiquetage des produits agricoles on a
vu cette semaine fin de semaine dernière
des barquettes de viande irlandaise être
étiqueté d'un labelle viande bovine
française et bien cela a été partagé sur
les réseaux sociaux écoutez la réponse
sur ce sujet très précis de Bruno Le
Maire troème chose sur laquelle nous
veillons particulièrement c'est la
tromperie du consommateur qui est aussi
le vol du producteur quand vous avez un
poulet sur lequel vous avez un
étiquetage avec un drapeau tricolore
c'est une tromperie du consommateur et
c'est c'est un vol du producteur qui lui
s'échine à travailler à cultiver à
produire en France sur le territoire
français avec les normes françaises et
avec les réglementations françaises là
aussi nous avons multiplié les contrôles
les industriels qui s'amusent à mettre
des drapeaux tricolore sur des produits
qui viennent de l'étranger s'expos à une
sanction qui pourra aller jusqu'à 15 %
de leur chiffre d'affair là aussi les
sanctions tomberont et personne ne
passera entre les mailles du filet voilà
Bruno Le Maire très volontariste hier en
séance on verra s'il y a de nouvelles
annonces d'ici au 24 février date
d'ouverture du salon agriculture auou
Public Sénat sera n'est-ce pas Tam bien
sûr merci merci beaucoup Quentin on vous
retrouve tout au long de ce débrief
François patria lilois et Galim avaient
pour objectif bien d'assurer un revenu
décent aux agriculteurs on entend à
niveau à nouveau Bruno Lemire donc qui
menace qui dit qu'il va y avoir des
sanctions comment le croire quand on
voit qu'elles n'ont pas été appliqué
jusqu'ici d'abord rappelons que les lois
et Galim issues des états généraux de
l'alimentation sont en est de progrès
par rapport au loi qu' y avait avant qui
était la loi LME qui faisait la partie
forte au grand distributeur et au
transformateurs vous voyez que ce n'est
pas suffisant avec la
crise agricurs dans cette loi les
agriculteurs le reconnaissent je les ai
rencontré comme beaucoup d'entre nous
elle a permis des améliorations elle a
permis sur le lait sur les œufs c'est
des produits d'avoir de meilleures
rentabilités pour les producteurs elle
est aujourd'hui détourné soit par les
transformateurs soit par les
distributeurs à côté pour se faire il
faut évidemment M Ier c'est ce que fait
le gouvernement avec à la fois beaucoup
de fermeté de détermination multiplier
les contrôles on a vu qu'il y a toujours
aujourd'hui il y a des il y a des
entreprises qui ont essayé de détourner
la loi et il y a eu des centrales
d'achat qui se sont installées hors de
nos frontières elles seront maintenant
surveillé et contrôlé comme les autres
donc la loi égalime c'est un progrès
elle a apporté des progrès elle a des
carences aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a des
gens qui cherchent à la détourner et
bien le gouvernement fait preuve à la
fois de volontarisme et de fermeté pour
essayer d'y remédier et faire en sorte
qu'il y ait des sanctions il va y avoir
des sanctions il déjà eu il y en aura de
plus importantes on entend les menaces
du gouvernement lence Garnier vous y
croyez aujourd'hui ce qui me frappe
d'abord c'est la souffrance terrible de
nos agriculteurs j'étais à leur côté
comme un certain nombre de mes collègues
lors des jours qui ont vu cette cette
colère agricole s'exprimer et les
slogans notre fin F sera votre fin
faim je crois qu'il faut revenir à une
forme de bon sens on a a besoin en
France de nos paysans de nos
agriculteurs pour nourrir les Français
et pour les nourrir d'une manière qui
soit qualitative puisqu'ils produisent
quelle que soit l'agriculture que ce
soit de l'agriculture biologique que ce
soit de l'agriculture conventionnelle
ils produisent aujourd'hui une
alimentation des produits de qualité
alors effectivement forcé de constater
vous l'avez fait et nous sommes nombreux
à le faire que les les lois et les
mesures qui ont été prises qu'elles
concernent la France ou le aujourd'hui
ne sont pas à la hauteur nos
agriculteurs souhaitent vivre décemment
d'un métier qui est fondamental qu'il
faut reconnaître moi j'en ai aussi marre
de cette Agri bachine qu'on entend
parfois ici au là dans nos grandes
agglomérations je suis nantaise je
l'entends à Nant et je l'entends
ailleurs REM fris on quand même très
mivement
soutenu véritablement je m'en réjouis
oui vous savez qu'on a quand même un
certain nombre d'associations
environnementalistes qui ne manque pas
une occasion de porter devant les
juridiction adaptées des des des actions
de nos agriculteur qui ensuite sont
obligés et ça ce sont des faits de les
dédommager financièrement pour alimenter
encore cet agribaching qui existe en
France il faut le dire maintenant wait
eny pour répondre directement à votre
question je me réjouis de la
détermination affichée par le ministre
mais il est à la tête du ministère je
crois depuis 2017 et nous en sommes à la
situation que nous constatons
aujourd'hui donc white NC j'appelle
effectivement à ce qu'on soutienne avec
la plus grande fermeté nos agriculteurs
nous avons besoin d'eux Thas desu de
l'agribaching du côté des écologistes je
pense pas je pense pas même dans nos
grandes villes comme vous le dites je
pense à Lyon où on a augmenté la part
d'agriculture locale dans les dans les
assiettes des cantines ou des ou des
épades je pense que tout le monde fait
sa fait sa part mais là on voit bien que
la loi égalime dont vous parler n'a pas
atteint son but elle a pas atteint son
but alors on découvre avec le ministre
que peut-être c'est parce qu' n'a pas eu
assez de contre contrôle et ça assez
étonnant puisque depuis quelques
semaines c'est aros sur les services
publics de contrôle sur les différents
agents qui font qui opère des contrôles
et là d'un coup on se rend compte qu'ils
ont une utilité qui pourrait faire mieux
appliquer la loi donc on va attendre de
voir si les belles déclarations du
ministre parce qu'il est un peu le
champion de ces ces grands coups de
menton un peu dans le vent on va
attendre de voir s'il y a du concret
derrière mais ce qu'on sait c'est que
l'année dernière le prix d'achat de la
production agricole a baissé de 9 % et
le prix de vente des produits agricoles
en bout de course des produits
alimentaires en bout de course dans la
grande distribution a augmenté de 8 %.
entre les deux il y a quelque chose qui
ne va pas c'est-à-dire des agriculteurs
qui n'arrivveent pas à vivre de leur
production et des prix de plus en plus
élevés pour les consommateurs et donc là
il va falloir trouver un moyen de
réguler un peu mieux ça et donc je sais
pas si égalim est encore au niveau pour
ça ou s'il va pas falloir retravailler
ce dispositif oui l'autre sujet qui a
été marquant et Quentin en a parlé tout
à l'heure hein et bien c'était la
question qu'a posé votre président de
groupe Guillaume Gontard qui a demandé
et bien si dans cette séquence
l'écologie n'était pas en train d'être
sacrifiée pour l'agriculture on écoute
cette séquence et on revient d'ici en
plateau lors de votre déclaration de
politique générale vous avez décidé de
hurler avec les loups en évoquant une
écologie de la brutalité nouvelle
stratégie de diversion estampillée minsé
vous faites ainsi vôre le propos de ceux
qui à droite et à l'extrême droite n'ont
jamais eu la moindre ambition écologique
votre unique objectif qui n'a rien de
populaire et de préserver coûte que
coûte la capacité des plus aisés à
polluer et émettre trois fois plus de
CO2 que les plus modestes pourtant le
président en campagne avait déclaré ce
quinquena sera écologique ou ne sera pas
alors Monsieur le Premier Ministre quand
démarrera le quinquena ce que je ne
comprends pas davantage c'est d'avoir
entendu et vu des élus écologistes aller
sur les barrages aller au côté des
agriculteurs ces dernières semaines
pendant leur mouvement pour dire qu'ils
épousaient leurs revendication et qu'ils
étaient à leur côté et les soutenaient
et depuis que nous avons trouvé une
solution et donner des perspectives aux
agriculteurs en lien avec eux il y a
quelques jours maintenant critiquer
méthodiquement toutes les solutions qui
ont été trouvé avec nos agricultrices et
nos agriculteurs je ne le comprends pas
il ne vous comprend pas Thomas dessus
ouais enfin moi j'étais encore sur un
barrage vendredi après les annonces il y
a certains agriculteurs qui ne se
satisfaisaient pas des annonces
notamment sur le recul sur les normes
environnementales et les produits
phytosanitaires on a on a un vrai sujet
de santé publique qu'il faut qui qu'on
ne peut pas esquiver et quand
j'entendais le Premier ministre dire
qu'on opposait les grandes villes au au
milieu rural en fait les les les points
de captage d'eau potables qui sont
fermés à cause de de résidus de
pesticides trop élevés ce sont dans les
zones rurales donc on voit bien que
c'est aussi il faut travailler sur la
réduction des des des des produits
d'intran chimique et je pense pas que le
recul du gouvernement aille dans la
bonne direction non Laurence stin est-ce
que vous craignez que l'environnement
soit le grand sacrifi de cette séquence
avec notamment la mise en pause du plan
écopyo qui était réclamé par les
agriculteurs et qui a donc lieu d'abord
de remarque je pense que le premier
ministre ne devrait pas répondre en en
antagonisant comme il le fait d'un côté
les agriculteurs et ceux qui les
soutiennent de l'autre côté les
écologistes et ceux qui les soutiennent
c'est pas comme ça ni qu'on règlera
collectivement la question agricole ni
qu'on créera la dynamique et l'adhésion
indispensable à la transition écologique
moi j'aiattends du Premier ministre qu'
antagonisé parce que quand il a dit à
moment la planète doit tous nous rassem
je trouve que là dans le propos qu'on a
ilagonise parce que y a discours qui
estz facile qui consiste à les
agriculteurs sont les victimes
d'agrobaching et puis d'un autre et les
écologistes veulent s'en prenent nos
agriculteurs je pense que c'est d'abord
je pense que les premières victimes des
intran c'està-dire des pesticides des
engrais chimiques ce sont les
agriculteurs et ça me désole ça me
désole de voir que des professions
François patria est là on pourrait
parler de l'impact sur sur les
viticulteurs en particulier des
traitements des traitements chimiques et
de l'augmentation du cancer de la
prostate chez les viticulteurs et ça me
désole de voir que en fait on n'aide pas
ces professions à trouver les solutions
qui sont à la fois protectrices de leur
santé accessoirement de cette des
consommateurs mais c'est même pas le
sujet que j'aborde à l'instant et en
même temps qui leur garantisseent un
revenu et des conditions de travail
acceptables pour eux je sais je pense
qu'il faut avoir en tête que ce qu'on
demande au agriculteurs avec la
transition écologique est une contrainte
supplémentaire c'est
incontestable mais il faut leur garantir
un revenu si on veut avec que vers la
transition écologique il faut leur
garantir un revenu et il faut leur
garantir aussi le passage parce que
sinon on va se retrouver dans quelques
années on aura le même débat la même
discussion les marchés internationaux
vont continuer d'emporter le libéralisme
et le libre échangisme sur les matières
agricoles va continuer de dévaster la
planète nos agriculteurs vont continuer
d'avoir des d'être de moins en moins
nombreux sur des exploitations de plus
en plus grande et on va continuer
ensemble de constater les impacts sur la
santé excusez-moi mais je pense qu'un
gouvernement doit être cohérent je fini
là-dessus on peut pas le lundi ou la
semaine précédente nous demander de
faire davantage d'enfants parler du
réarmement démographique et annoncer ce
qui est une excellente chose un plan de
lutte contre l'infertilité et la semaine
suivante dire open barre pour les pour
les pesticides alors qu'on sait que
c'est un des facteurs importants
d'infertilité masculine il faut traiter
tout ça avec davantage de sérieux
Françis patr incohérence non attende non
mais parce que là il y a des choses que
j'entends mais qui sont pas réelles
première chose d'abord il y a-t-il eu un
recul sur l'écologie comme vous le dites
où est le recul a-t-on changé une des
molécules qui éta interdite non a-t-on
eston revenu sur les zedn zone de nos
traitement non sur écopyo ça n'est pas
un recul aujourd'hui c'est que le plan
écopyo français tel qu'il est
conçu français est en avant sur le plan
écophito européen ce qui veut dire que
si on restait au niveau des cofito tel
qu'il est conçu en France demain on aura
une nouvelle surtransposition on sera
encore plus exigeant qu'avec les autres
partenaires européens et de ce fait là
et ben on va encore diminuer leur part
de marché de ce qui veut dire que si on
veut effectivement avancer ensemble il
faut avancer ensemble avec les Européens
sur le plan écofyo et trouver un plan
écofyo qu'on puisse contrôler demain et
pas à nouveau créer une distorsion
deatri mais les plans écopito il y en a
eu plusieurs he c'est le trè il y en a
eu un en 2008 il devait réduire de 50%
l'usage des pesticides en 10 ans il n'a
pas été atteint le deuxième n'a pas été
atteint non plus donc on a quand même le
sentiment que quoi qu'il arrive que soit
on se prévoit des objectifs trop
importants soit et bien on ne remplit
pas en tout cas ces objectifs je crois
que le mod d'ordre était de dire pas de
transformation sans solution moi je
pense qu'il faut avancer avec des
solutions et que la recherche soit aidée
mieux pour le faire aujourd'hui mais
aujourd'hui priver les agriculteurs de
solutions sur des produit dans lesquels
on devient dépendant je donne un seul
exemple d'avoir arrêté les
néonicotinoïdes sur le cols on était
gros gros producteur de colza
aujourd'hui on produit plus de colza en
France et on importe du colza d'Europe
centrale et d'ailleurs avec des né voilà
voilà le travail le pesticide de tueur
d'abeilles Thomas Dosu quand on dit il y
a pas d'alternative donc on doit
continuer comme ça il faut encourager la
science l'anes produit régulièrement des
listes d'alternatives je crois que
c'était une vingtaine
auticoïde pardon qui on été publié par
l'ances on a des agences qui travaillent
là-dessus on les plans écophyo c'est pas
on stoppe du jour au lendemain les
pesticides c'est des trajectoires qu' il
faut respecter mais pour cela ça demande
de l'accompagnement et quand on on fait
des trajectoires avec des objectifs sans
accompagnement et ben effectivement les
plus petits ceux qui ont qui souffrent
le plus dès qu'on change une norme et
ben ils en paâtissent le plus et donc
aujourd'hui on est dans un dans un dans
un système où les plus gros arriveront
toujours à s'en sortir et les plus
petits parce que ce gouvernement n'est
pas capable de les accompagner mordront
toujours la poussière et donc mais donc
vous comprenez qu'on fixe des objectifs
que certains ne peuvent pas atteindre et
craignent donc de mettre le cl sous la
porte aussi c'estàdire que quand on fixe
des objectifs comme ça il faut faut
prévoir l'accompagnement qui suit sinon
on n'y arrivera pas c'est mais c'est
surt les sujets écologiques c'est pareil
hein sur tous les sujets écologiques dès
qu'on peut on on met une pause on
s'arrête parce qu'en fait on narrive pas
à accompagner correctement la transition
je sont les PL é pardonnez-moi je vais
prolonger les propos de mon collègue
parce que de fait vous mettez le doigt
sur quelque chose de très juste que ce
soit sur le plan écofyo comme sur un
certain nombre de dispositifs le
gouvernement affiche des intentions qui
sont parfois bonnes bien sûr que tout le
monde veut aller dans le sens d'une
agriculture plus respectueuse de
l'environnement les agriculteurs
eux-mêmes mais prenons en élargissant un
peu le sujet la question des ZFE des
zones à faible émission qui devaent être
mise en application actuellement on a
reculé bien sûr que dans l'affichage
tout le monde souhaite qu'il y ait moins
d'émission mais dans les fait ça n'est
pas possible et donc on fait trop
souvent je trouve avec ce gouvernement
qui dont je peux partager un certain
nombre de bonnes intentions de la
communication de l'affichage et ensuite
des recul on se donne pas les moyens de
de faire cette politique dans les fait
ce n'est pas possible je vrais juste
qu'on s'arrête un instant sur cette
phrase qu'est-ce qui n'est pas possible
dans les fait la transition écologique
de l'agriculture elle n'est pas possible
de français d'accéder au métropole dans
les fait
aujourd'hui on parla pas mais
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est possible
c'est on a presque envie dire mais ce
qu'on voit n'est pas possible n'est pas
imaginable quand on parle du plan écopyo
de quoi on parle de la biodiversité
quelles sont les premières victimes de
la perte de la biodiversité les
agriculteurs ce sont les premières
victimes quel c'est ça dont on parle et
alors j'entends bien ce que dit François
patri à un instant oui on fait rentrer
des produits européens et ce bon ok mais
depuis des années on est un certain
nombre à dire que on a un problème de
protectionnisme voilà que à un moment
donné le sacroin marché libéral l'OMC et
tout ce qui a été mis en place n'était
pas n'était pas compatible avec nos
objectifs pour la planète et même avec
le main du pouvoir d'achat des des
Français et des Européens l'idéologie
c'est de l'idéologie à rejeté toute
critique du protectionnisme toute
critique du libéralisme et du et de
l'OMC et on est passé pour des ringards
les protectionnistes aujourd'hui quel
est le sujet c'est celui du
protectionnisme et de la souveraineté
alimentaire et bien entendu ça ne se
fera pas en continuant d'importer
effectivement je comprends que les
agriculteurs soient scandalisés quand il
voit qu'on importe des produits qui ont
poussé avec ce que ils n'ont pas le
droit d'util
incontestablement mais l'enjeu
écologique c'est marrant le Sénat ce
matin il y avait une réunion des deux
commissions affaires sociales et
aménagement du territoire sur lesco
anxiété tout le monde il y avait des psy
des gens des professionnels et tout le
monde s'est intéressé c'est quoi
l'écoanxiété quel est l'impact et cetera
et lescoanxiété on a compris c'est pas
une maladie c'est juste une perception
du monde dans lequel on vit et en fait
ce qui augmente les CP anxiété qui a des
conséquences sur la natalité par exemple
c'est le fait fait que les pouvoirs
publics ne donnent pas aux gens
l'impression qu'ils vont apporter les
solutions que les gens cherchent donc on
n pas simplement que le problème si vous
de laisser les agriculteurs faire ce
qu'ils ont envie de faire parce que
quand même c'est un peu ça puis le
ministre les ministres de l'agriculture
c'est moi je comprends pas trop bien
parce que la FNSEA cirige la politique
agricole dans ce pays et c'est la FNSEA
qui critique la politique agricole de ce
pays à un moment donné où je comprends
pas totalement comment les choses se
passent mais aujourd'hui ça Rouve aussi
un peu débordé en l'occurrence sur cette
crise non mais je voulais juste
simplement dire que on a une autre on a
une lourde responsabilité qui est aussi
celui de l'avenir qu'on indique aux
Français est-ce que l'avenir qu'on leur
dit c'est qu'on a un gouvernement et des
pouvoirs publics et des responsables qui
vont prendre à bras le corp la question
écologique ou est-ce que on va donner
l'impression de céder régulièrement
devant tel ou tel groupe de pression
économique une toute dernière réaction
et on va on va changer de TH j'entends
bien les agriculteurs eux-mêmes sont
conscients de l'environnement de
l'écologie la disparition de
l'appauvrissement de leur terre et
disparition des espèces ils en sont
conscients ils font des efforts
quotidiens le gouvernement les
accompagne malgré tout ce que j'ai pu
entendre par ailleurs mais dans le même
temps faire de l'écologie à marche
forcée ça n'est pas compatible avec le
consommateur et avec leur P à marche
forcée si demain on demande aux
agriculteurs français de
produire
marche attendez j'ai interrompu personne
merci merci bien donc la marche forc
qu'on va leur demander d'avoir des
contraintes supplémentaires et des coûts
supplémentaires qu'est-ce qu'ils feront
ils le feront ils mettront un produit
qui sera sur le marché qui sera boudé
par les consommateurs parce qu'ils iront
au prix plus bas à côté il vous savez là
il y a un moment un consommateur qui dit
qu'il veut les produits les plus sains
les meilleurs j'entends bien et dans le
même temps va toujours au prix les plus
bas alors forcez les AGC frateur
incohérent aussi c'est vrai donne com
c'est la réalité on va tout de suite
passer à un deuxième thème qui a
également marqué cette séance de
question au gouvernement Alexandre vous
êtes avec le sénateur de scè Saint-Denis
adelan qui a tout à l'heure interpellé
le gouvernement autour de la crise du
logement parler de la crise agricole il
y a aussi la crise du logement qui est
très forte et notamment sur l'une des
réponses du gouvernement qui veut et
bien modifier la loi SRU et oui on va en
parler bonjour adelsian bonjour alors il
y a eu un échange assez tendu entre vous
et le ministre Christophe Béchu sur
cette question de la crise du logement
le ministre vous reproche de pointer la
responsabilité le bilan du gouvernement
dans cette crise actuelle en France
alors que Christophe Béchu rappelle que
c'est aussi une crise européenne avec la
la hausse des des taux d'intérêt
également la hausse du prix des coûts du
matériau dans le bâtiment est-ce que
c'est pas un peu facile de taper sur le
gouvernement bah moi tout d'abord j'été
très étonné de la réaction du ministre
qui a été assez véhément on lui a
rappelé simplement un certain nombre de
vérités d'abord c'est pas une crise par
rapport à d'autres crises qu'on pu
éclater il y a quelques temps dans le
monde agricole les gilets jaunes les
ameutes urbaines et ca c'est une crise
qui vient de loin tout d'abord ça ne
date pas d'hier ça ne date pas d'une
crise des taux d'intérêt depuis 2017
déjà je le dis très clairement depuis le
premier quinquena du président de la
République il y a une non priorité donné
à cette question du logement on le voit
chaque année moi-même j'ai été élu à
l'aménagement et l'urbanisme à
saint-toin sur scène j'ai vu ce
désengagement de l'État progressif pour
aider les villes à produire du logement
social pour aider les villes à les
accompagner pour permettre au plus
fragiles de nos habitants de pouvoir se
loger dans de bonnes conditions les
chiffres qui sont sortis c'est ce que
j'ai rappelé au ministre Christophe
Béchu les chiffres de la Fondation Abé
piierre qui sont sortis il y a quelques
jours était catastrophique il y a une
accélération de cette crise du logement
et c'est ce que je lui ai rappelé alors
effectivement le gouvernement Gabriel
Attal l'a annoncé la semaine dernière a
pour ambition de réformer la loi SRU qui
je le rappelle prévoit dans les communes
urbaines un objectif de 20 à 25 % de
logements sociaux sur le territoire de
ces communes d'ici à 2025 et le
gouvernement veut intégrer dans cet
objectif SRU également des logements
intermédiaires accessibles aux classes
moyennes ça ça ne vous plaît pas cette
réforme ça va gonfler artificiellement
les chiffre du logement social euh
d'abord quand on parle du logement libre
intermédiaire c'est effectivement
effectivement une typologie de logement
et le plafond fond c'est des familles
avec on va dire 80000 € de ressources
par famille donc on n'est pas forcément
dans les classes populaires ou les
classes les plus fragiles ensuite la loi
srus c'est une véritable avancée dans
notre pays pour permettre une véritable
mixité une capacité pour que l'ensemble
des communes de notre pays puisse
participer à cet effort de loger les
habitants en particulier les habitants
qui sont dans des situations difficiles
cette loi su elle date des années 2000
2001 elle prévoit 25 % de logements
sociaux et pas du logement libre
intermédiaire ça n'a rien à voir 25 % de
logements sociaux certaines villes sont
largement au-dessus celles qui sont en
dessous euh en dessous des 25 % à 10 15
20 % payent des amendes parce qu'elles
doivent justement construire avec la
proposition c'est pour ça que je l'ai
dit nous étions consternés avec
l'ensemble de nos collègues et pas
seulement nos collègues mais les acteurs
publics les acteurs privés qui ont écrit
aux ministres les villes les
associations de locataires les bailleurs
et cetera et les secteurs les
professionnels du secteur immobilier du
secteur privé ont dit justement que
cette intégration du LLI dans les SRU
était à la fois un tour de pass-p
statistique et surtout ça n'allait pas
inciter à la production de logements
sociaux sachant qu'aujourd'hui on a 2,6
millions de Françaises et de français
qui sont en attente d'un logement social
donc c'est un nouveau coup porté au
secteur du logement social pour moi tout
à fait je ne comprends même pas pourquoi
si on a cette approche aujourd'hui je ne
vois pas en quoi et ça n'a pas été c'est
ce que j'attendais comme réponse de la
part de notre ministre Christophe Béchu
de m'expliquer l'intérêt de la part du
gouvernement de son point de vue en quoi
intégrer le lli qui n'est pas du
logement social dans l'a partart de
logements sociaux en quoi cela allait
permettre de relancer la son logements
sociaux il nous reste quelques secondes
c'est une crise complexe he cette crise
du logement s'il y avait une mesure une
solution à prendre en œuvre d'urgence
pour apporter une réponse à cette crise
la première c'est de vraiment être et
des propositions ont été faites à la
demande du gouvernement lors de la du
Conseil national de la refondation sur
le logement un package de solutions et
de propositions existe elles ont été
faites à destination du gouvernement par
l'ensemble des acteurs acteurs privés
mais également les acteurs publics les
collectivités une des premières mesures
c'est de vraiment aider en fonction
commune urb commune dans le rural dans
le péri urbain d'aider les villes à
pouvoir bénéficier d'un foncier qui leur
permette justement de construire du
logement social voilà ma proposition
celle le prix du foncier un
accompagnement de l'état de ce point de
VUL c'est une demande qui a été faite
refaite et on l'a refait aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup Adian pour votre première
réaction après votre première question
au gouvernement ma deuxème question
gouvernement V deuxème ici au Sénat je
vous remercie merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre vous êtes consterné Laurence
rignal comme le reste de votre groupe
vous ne comprenez pas cette mesure euh
du euh du gouvernement qui entend donc
modifier la loi SRU pour intégrer le
logement intermédiaire au côat de 25 %
de logement sociaux auquel les communes
sont assujéties aujourd'hui euh si je le
comprends politiquement c'est-à-dire que
quand on fait un gouvernement de droite
en faisant rentrer des personnalités de
droite et euh qu'on cherche à envoyer
des signaux exclusivement à droite euh
il faut bien satisfaire quelques-unes
des revendications traditionnelles de la
droite c'est en particulier le recul sur
la loi etru c'est une vieille affaire
mais la droite n'a jamais osé le faire
si ma mémoire est bonne ça de
gouvernement jepin la loi et rue sa
faire de ma part et je note quand même
que la droite n'a pas osé le faire ils
ont ont pensé mais là maintenant c'est
annoncé il était pas tant de d'adresser
aussi un message aux classes moyenne
parce qu'on a entendu beaucoup le
Premier ministre parler des classes
moyenes vous estimez que ça s'adress ça
dont il est question construire du
logement pour les classes moyennes tout
le monde est d'accord ceci dit je note
quand même qu'entre 2022 et 2023 le
nombre les les permis de construire ont
baissé de 23 % et les ouvertures de
chantiers de 22 % donc ça c'est pas
c'est chif de la Banque de France en
effet donc on est réellement dans une
crise du logement et je pense que le
gouvernement devrait pas le nier et on
est réellement dans un moment
préoccupant sur le logement la loi est
serue elle sert à quoi elle sert à la
mixité sociale alors j'ai bien noté que
la mixité sociale était pas le sujet de
la mise de l'éducation mais je pensais
pas que ça avait contaminer les autres
et donc c'est ça dont on parle alors on
a des aimutes urbaines en juillet et
puis en janvier suivant on annonce qu'on
revient sur la loi sus c'està dire qu'on
on recule dans la la volonté de mixité
sociale les communes j'en connais dans
mon propre département qui sont
tellement fiers de payer les amendes
pour non respect de la lois et ses rues
vont vont on gagner d'un certain point
de vue je pense quand même que la
conséquence est qu'on va leur réduire
leurs amendes ça me paraît assez assez
assez logique et aujourd'hui on est à la
fois on accroit cette politique elle
accroit la crise du logement elle
renonce à la mixité sociale elle laisse
des villes des getau de riche
pardonnez-moi d'expression un peu rapide
c'estàdire ne pas prendre en charge les
classes moyennes parce que aujourd
auourd'i 35 % de la combien de
pourcentage la population peut ACC au
logement social mais beaucoup plus que
simplement une fraction c'est beaucoup
donc les classes moyennes les classes
moyennes sont aussi concernées par
l'accession logement social alors
Françis patria est-ce que c'est un clin
d'œil à la droite que vous faites c'est
le le geste politique que lit Laurence
Rossignol dans dans ce que vous voulez
faire avec la lo chose que je n'aime pas
en politique c'est le cinisme l'amnésie
et puis dans le même temps la
condamnation sans appel là on est sur le
logement aujourd'hui les difficultés du
logement elles viennent essentiellement
de quoi avant de parler de laru viennent
du fait et le ministre l'a rappelé la
hausse des taux d'intérêt et la hausse
des produits pour la construction
formidable et cette crise du logement
elle touche tous les pays du monde tous
et on faut pas croire que la difficulté
du logement elle date de l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 que ceux à qui
ce qui disent ça aujourd'hui je leur
rappellerai que quand on a rien mis sur
la justice sur l'école sur la santé
pendant des années et j'en étais
coresponsable on peut pas aujourd'hui
donner des leçons au gouvernement dire
qu'il ne fait pas assez comm pour place
de prison on n pas construit de place de
prison pendant 20 ans on a déjà
construit 5000 sur 15000 on dit qu'on
fait pas
ass de prendez non mais pas du tout mais
je veux dire c'est tout c'est quand vous
dites depuis 2017 ce gouvernement ce
gouvernement qui a droit aujour ce
gouvernement je suis prêt à l'assumer
bilan contre bilan avec tous les bilans
que j'ai soutenu auparavant dans le
domaine de la
santéenvironnement dans le domaine de
l'école dans le domaine de la justice
dans tous les ain y compris du logement
le gouvernement a construit des logement
et je suis pas d'accord avec l'analyse
aujourd'hui on a besoin si on a besoin
aujourd'hui de mixité social il faut
aussi construire des logements
intermédiaires parce que si on met tous
les GAMP pour dans les mêmes quartiers
en même temps alors là
aujourdhui est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit
intégré dans dans dans ces 25 % moi je
connais un collègue connaissussi bien la
ville de Dijon où il y a des m
bâtisseurs il y en a un qui a construit
20000 logements qui a construit 20000
logements il a construit du logement
social il a construit du logement
intermédiaire il aujourd'hui il ne
refuse pas la proposition qu'il fait au
gouvernement de mettre à la fois du
logement intermédiaire et du logement
social parce qu'il a déjà parce qu'il a
déjà largement atteint voir dépasser son
son donc ça ve dire ça dépend pas du
gouvernement ça dépend des maires ça
dépend des maires en par de ce choix là
qui a été fait aujourd'hui qui a été
fait et le gouvernement peut pas
toujours accompagner accompagner
accompagner j'entends bien il mais
aujourd'hui des sommes conséquentes et
dans le budget elles sont inscrites
comme tell pour de logement faire ce
procès maniquéen je trouve que c'est un
peuz Laurence Garnier votre regard sur
la crise du logement aujourd aujourd'hui
hein je rappelle le constat fait par la
Fondation Abé pierre elle parle d'une
crise inédite et elle a dénoncé aussi
bien ce qu'elle a considéré comme une
réponse uniquement budgétaire de la part
du gouvernement alors il y a la question
du logement social et puis a la question
du logement dans son ensemble dans son
ensemble sur la question du logement
social madame rossignal je je me permets
simplement de vous signaler que les
maires qui n'ont pas suffisamment de
logements sociaux et qui ne respectent
pas aujourd'hui la loi SRU ils sont de
toutes les sensibilités politiques
je le vois dans mon département de la
Loire Atlantique il certains sont de
gauche certains sont de droite ils ont
hérité d'une situation ils font des eff
on respecte pas à la chapelle sur Herde
c'est un maire de gauche qui n'est pas
dans les clous pour le logement social
dans d'autres communes ce sont des m de
droite et et et c'est comme ça et j'aime
pas beaucoup cette stigmatisation qui
consisterait à dire que la droite ne
souhaite pas logés les plus fragiles
d'entre nous c'est faux par contre nous
avons une
question
viens juste après euh par contre on a un
enjeu sur qui vit réellement dans les
logements sociaux à Nantes on s'est
aperçu que plus de la moitié des ménages
qui vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
sont dans le logement libre c'est-à-dire
que le logement social aujourd'hui dans
notre pays ne sert pas à loger ou ne
sert pas suffisamment pour être précise
à loger ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
et puis sur le logement de manière plus
générale je rejoins ce qu'a dit mon
collègue François patri ministre Béchu
bien sûr qu'il y a une crise
conjoncturelle liée à la hausse des taux
d'intérêt et des coûts de construction
il y a une crise qui est aussi
structurel lié à ce que lins appelle le
dcerment des ménages la décohabitation
le fait que entre les les séparations
l'allongement de la durée de la vie on
est de plus en plus seul c'est important
de le rappeler parce qu'il faut de plus
en plus de logement pour loger un même
nombre de personnes ce que je regrette
en revanche c'est que le gouvernement a
pris un certain nombre de mesures qui
viennent ajouter de la difficulté à la
difficulté je pense à la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui pour un certain nombre de
mares accueillir de nouveaux habitants
ce sont des charges supplémentaires des
classes dans les écoles de l'accueil
périscolaire sans ressources
supplémentaires donc c'est une
difficulté et je crois qu'elle est
réelle pour un certain nombre d'élus
locaux et puis la question du Zéro
artificialisation nette en Loire
Atlantique les coûts d'achat explose ce
sont des logements qui en l'espace de 4
ans ont été multipliés par deux en terme
de prix
est cont conruire àuse DEES lois ah
encore un sujet sur lequel et bien les
les questions environnementales viennent
se confronter à la crise actuelle les
artificialisation net pour lutter contre
et bien l'artificialisation des sols et
qui estime qu'on doit bah construire
différemment moins enidé sur les ESP de
Biers prop Gabri pas d'opposer l'urbain
et le rural et je pense que
artificialiser des terres c'est pas
forcément la bonne solution mais je revi
sur le cvage politique sur le logement
puisque moi je suis élu sur la métropole
de Lyon il se trouve il y a SEP communes
dont le droit démettre des permis de
construire a été repris par l'État SEP
communes et ces SEP communes sont chez
les républicains son sont des maires les
républicains puisqu on a une ensemble de
maire de droite qui ne veulent plus
construmoi pas faire de généralité pour
autantord mais il y a quand même une
grande majorité de Mair de droite qui ne
veulent pas accueillir de logements
sociaux qui font même campagne sur cette
questionl et donc on a besoin
d'appliquer la loi telle qu'elle est
c'était une loi qui permettait d'avoir
un accueil une mixité sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'est très important et donc
on accepte mieux le logement social s'il
est si on n pas 80 % de logement social
dans sa ville et donc pour ça il faut
que d'autres villes en accueill aussi et
donc casser l'indicateur comme le fait
le gouvernement je pense que ça va dans
la mauvaise direction et moi je vais
dédoiner aussi ce gouvernement il y a
pas de mesure d'urgence magique qu'on
pourrait prendre maintenant pour régler
ce problème là la crise elle est énorme
elle est mulctori elle date quand même
depuis un moment même le gouvernement
s'en est inquiété puisquil a il a il a
monté un un CNR sur le logement et puis
les les conclusions n'ont pas du tout
été reprises pourtant c'était des
conclusions partagées à la fois par la
patronne de Next City promoteur
immobilier et en même temps le président
de la la Fondation la baépierre et et
les deux ces deux acteurs pourtant très
éloignés ont été très déçus par
l'attitude du gouvernement sur cette
question et on a besoin cette fois-ci
d'avoir un gouvernement qui ne prend pas
ça comme une crise d'urgence mais qui
travaille sur des solutions de fond qui
ont été produites par le CNR et
notamment sur le foncier je pense il y
aura une loi logement il y aura une loi
logement Françis patria oui il y a aussi
une mission d'information du Sénat
actuellement parce que on a compris
c'est un sujet le gouvernement dans le
paquet des lois qui propose avant le
premier semestre proposera une loi sur
le logement oui pour changer la loi et
ses rues c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
une traiter l'ensemble des problèmes
pour traiter l'ensemble du problème bon
ENF avancer avec les moyens
d'aujourd'hui il y a pas un coup de
baguette magique sur le logement
aujourd'hui ça existait quelque part
d'autres pays s'en seraiit déjà emparé
or tout le monde est dans la même la
même confrontation que nous allez on
continue déb de ces questions au
Gouvernement un autre temps fort qui a
marqué cette séance de questions on va
rejoindre Quentin dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat c'était le temps qui était
consacré au sujet de l'audiovisuel
publque et là aussi il y a une réforme
qui s'annonce Quentin oui avec à la clé
une petite annonce Tam on savait que
Rachid adti la nouvelle ministre de la
Culture entendait reprendre le chantier
de la création d'une holding de l'UDEL
public pour créer des synergies entre
Radio France d'un côté France Télévision
de l'autre un chantier déjà ouvert par
Franck rester début 2020 et même adopté
en commission à l'Assemblée nationale en
mars 2020 mais un projet mis à l'arrêt
par la crise du covid les sénateurs sont
revenus à la charge l'année dernière ont
voté une proposition de loi pour aller
dans ce sens c'était en le 13 juin
dernier et donc tout à l'heure pendant
la séance rachidti a fait une petite
annonce en l'écoute il ne faut pas se
dérober et il faut pouvoir répondre à
ces jeux cruciaux alors moi je plaide
pour un audiovisuel public qui rassemble
toutes ces forces
ça correspond évidemment à votre texte
je sais que ces attentes il y a des
attentes très fortes sur ces sujets
alors moi j'avancerai en concertation
évidemment avec vous je m'appuierai je
le dis ici je l'avais pas précisé
auparavant je m'appuierai sur votre
texte sur votre PPL monsieur le
Président Laffond voilà pour revenir sur
le texte effectivement de Laurent Lafond
il visait à créer une holding pour
définir une stratégie accélérer les
coopération et optimiser la répartition
des moyens aussi face à la concurrence
des plateforme de streaming comme
Netflix ou encore Disney plus cette
proposition avait été accueillie avec
scepticisme on peut le dire par les
syndicats de salariés qui craignaient de
nouveaux objectifs d'économie Tam merci
merci beaucoup Quentin qu'est-ce que ça
vous a
inspiré cette séquence où on a vu et
bien notamment Rachid adati qui a rendu
hommage et bien à de très nombreux
sénateurs de droite notamment gen r
Hugonet Roger carucci on a André gatolin
aiste auss qui maronist qui éoniste
qu'est-ce que ça vous a inspiré que
c'est un revirement du gouvernement
puisque la ministre précédente Rima
abdoumak était en séance précédemment
sur les textes qui ont été évoqués et
qui était opposé à cette la création de
cet holding c'est un retour à franester
aussi oui peut-être mais en tout cas la
ministre précédente il éta opposé pour
des bonnes raisons c'est-à-dire que
depuis le covid ces synergies donc
l'appel de ces vux se sont créé entre
les différents groupes de l'audiovisuel
public mais aussi quelle est la
l'urgence de de cela euh l'audiovisuel
public connaît des audiences record je
pense à Radio France par exemple qui
quel que soit les antennes connaisent
des audiences euh au-dessus de du de de
l'audiovisuel privé par exemple euh
l'audiovisuel public se développe
massivement sur les les les les
plateformes en ligne euh et donc on a un
travail qui est déjà en en en place mais
on voit bien qu'après la suppression euh
de l' redevance on va créer une holding
pour euh réunir un état-major et on peut
craindre une miss sous tutelle un peu
plus encore de l'audioovisuel public
avec cette fois-ci une une une main mise
de selon les gouvernements sur le le le
haut de de de tout ça est-ce que c'est
verceela qu'on s'oriente mis sous
tutelle de de l'audiovisuel publique
aujourd'hui un contrôle de l'audiovisuel
public aujourd'hui écoutez très
sincèrement moi je n'y comprends plus
grand-chose ça fait ça a été rappelé
quelques années maintenant qu'on parle
de cette réforme de l'audiovisuel public
on a l'occasion les uns et les autres
d'échanger avec des journalistes euh qui
nous font part de leurs interrogations
de leurs incompréhensions de fait depuis
4 ans on ne sait pas ce qui va se passer
ou ne pas se passer euh on a des
ministres qui reprennent à leur compte
euh les propositions portées par le
Sénat d'autres qui ne les reprennent pas
on a des temps morts on entend
aujourd'hui Rachid hadti nous dire
qu'elle va s'inspirer euh du rapport de
la commission culture éducation
communication dont je suis membre he et
et avec un certain nombre de de de
propositions pour forcer structurer
notre audiovisuel public mais c'est vrai
que nous avons maintenant Rachid adti
ministre de la Culture nous avions
paravant Rima abdoumayak qui était
presque à l'opposé des des de la ligne
politique de Rachid hadti je vous avoue
que je n'y comprends plus grand-chose et
je ne suis pas la seule en tout état de
cause je trouve que c'est une très
mauvaise idée de laisser traîner ce
sujet qui vous avez quand même
l'impression qu'elle est en total accord
avec vous parce que c'est quand même ce
qu'elle a dit tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle qu'elle voulait absolument
repr prendre la proposition de loi du
Sénat de la majorité sénatoriale mais
vous savez nous on fait preuve de
cohérence sur ce sujet-l comme sur
d'autres quand la majorité
gouvernementale veut s'appuyer sur les
travaux de la majorité sénatoriale ça
nous convient maintenant là encore
attendons de voir on a entendu tellement
de choses pour finalement très peu de
résultats attendons tellement de serment
d'amour Laurence rosignol qu'est-ce que
ça vous inspirec moi je ne suis pas une
spécialiste de ces sujets mais en
revanche je sais capter ce qu'on
appellerait des signaux faibles et ça
fait j'ai entendu dans la bouche d'un
des sénateurs qui a posé la question cet
après-midi je l'ai entendu dans la
bouche de la ministre dans la semaine
dans une radio et l'histoire que en fait
il faudrait réformer l'audiovisuel
public pour y mettre du pluralisme c'est
quoi cette histoire de pluralisme dans
l'audiovisuel public qui pense
aujourd'hui elle l'a dit la ministre et
c'était dans les propos du sénateur qui
pense aujourd'hui qu'on a un problème de
pluralisme dans le dans le service
public de l'audiovisuel que ce soit télé
ou radio qui pense aujourd'hui que nous
n'avons pas des bons journalistes
d'investigation dans le service public
qui pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut donner
plus de voix à des gens qu'on
n'entendrait pas dans l'audiovisuel
public en fait ce qu'il y a derrière
tout ça et qui est très inquiétant c'est
une critique culturelle de l'audiovisuel
public alors s'il faut aligner tout le
monde vous voulez dire quoi juger trop à
gauche c'est ça le je vous je vous ai
laissé le dire mais comme c'est c'est ce
qui se dit sur ces news s'il faut
aligner tous les médias de France sur ce
de Boloré autant qu'on nous prévienne et
je mets le gouvernement en garde
vraiment là-dessus on a une bataille
culturelle à mener aujourd'hui et cette
bataille culturelle elle annonce une
bataille politique lourde pour demain
cette bataille culturelle elle passe par
l'information non pas la propagande ça
la propagande on la voit sur un certain
nombre de chaînes de télé et de radio et
de médias elle passe par l'information
c'est-à-dire une information objective
une de de de l'enquête du travail de
journalistes c'est des chaînes qui
tiennent le dessus du pavé sont des
chaînes qui n'ont aucun journaliste qui
toute la journée font défiler des
propagandistes d'extrême droite et c'est
elles elles sont elles ont pas de
problème de pluralisme mais il est où le
problème de pluralisme donc moi je suis
très inquiète de ce qu'il y a derrière
cette affaire et qui en particulier
viserait à remettre en cause la qualité
d'information et de journalisme et
d'investigation qui sont inhérantes au
service public de l'audiovisuel François
patri est-ce que vous estimez qu'auourhi
y a un problème de pluralisme dans
l'audiovisuel public comme disait un peu
Colu je je me marre quand j'entends dire
aujourd'hui qu'il y aurait des radios ou
des télés ou des médias qui serviraient
la soupe au gouvernement moi je regarde
des médias tous les jours écoutez j'ai
le sentiment de l'entendre dans tous les
M que critique que critique systématique
que macrobashing et cetera surtout les
chat j'ai pas le sentiment aujourd'hui
que l'audiovisuel public comme souite
collègue dit soutienne avec beaucoup de
ferveur le gouvernement il joue son rôle
tout à fait normal d'indépendance de de
qualité je trouve que nous avons un
service public de qualité
faut faut le renforcer il faut le
renforcer aujourd'hui face au
déferlement de je vois de certaines
chaises aujourd'hui qui effectivement
nobéissent à aucune déontologie
politique en tout cas et le fait de le
renforcer faut savoir est-ce qu'on veut
un système public qui aujourd'hui reste
faible face aux grandes plateformes vous
les elles ont été évoquées tout à
l'heure par le par la ministre ou bien
on veut un système public fort alors
est-ce qu'il faut ou pas une synergie
entre les deux moi j'avoue ne pas être
un spécialiste de la question
aujourd'hui j'avais entendu ce que
disait rester j'avais entendu Rima sur
ce sujet je crois que là l'arbitre
l'arbitrage doit se faire au plus haut
niveau de l'État au niveau du Premier
ministre et du président de la
République dans ce domaine si demain on
arrive à renforcer par par un non pas en
fusionnant mais en rassemblant ces deux
entités qu'elles sont plus fortes qu'ell
ne s passent pas forcément par des
licenciement par desmissions de moyens
s'il y a plus de moyens derrière ça me
paraîtra aujourd'hui parfaitement
positif François patri qui a on avait
prévu hein cette émission avec quatre
personnalités politiques notamment pour
parler de ce remanimement ce
remanimement qui ne vient donc toujours
pas je vous donne quand même les
dernières informations maintenant on
nous dit que la deuxième moitié du
gouvernement Atal sera annoncée plutôt
demain que après actuellement Gabriel
hatal est à l'Élysée et que le séminaire
gouvernemental qui était prévu donc
demain on devait parler un petit peu de
la feuille de route et donc reporter
Fran c'est le jour de la marmotte c'est
le jour de la marmotte j sans un jour
sans fin c'est c'est long quand même
François patria que ce que que ce
remanimement non vous ne pensez pas plus
d'un mois enfin quasim un mois pour
pouvoir nommer et bien les les les 15
ministres secrétair d'État
supplémentaires c'est trèsile
aujourduiétat le chef de l'État veulent
avoir aujourd'hui un gouvernement de
combat parce que il y a des difficultés
qui sont évoquées être évoqué à
l'instant pour se faire il a nommé des
ministres régaliens qui aujourd'hui sont
à la tâche et on les voit en réponse au
gouvernement il travaillent tous les
jours avec des administrations qui n'ont
pas dit disparu si les ministres ne sont
pas nommés aujourd'hui mais les ordres
peuvent venir à la fois du chef du
gouvernement et des ministres régaliens
alors si on doit souffrir un jour de
plus est-ce que la France va mourir
est-ce qu'on va se pamer est-ce qu'il y
aura des malaises est-ce qu'il y aura
difficultés non enfin bon alors donc on
va pouvoir on va pouvoir patienter 24
heur moi ce qui compte c'est pas la
rapidité avec laquelle ils sont nommés
est-ce que les personnes qui seront
nommées demain je fais conférence au
gouvernement seront des personnes qui
seront compétences quel que soit leur
étiquette politique c'est pas ça le le
gouvernement que les gens viennent de
droite ou de gauche moi je pense que
quand il mène une politique qui va dans
le sens de l'intérêt général du
développement de notre pays du
réarmement du pays qu'importe l'origine
d'où ils viennent aujourd'hui sauf sil
vient des extrêmes bien entendu on a
compris mais s'il a des gens aujourd'hui
de droite et de gauche qui sont capables
de se mettre au service de la nation et
moi j'aiant travaillé avec Monsieur
Dupont Moretti d' dit qu'il est de
gauche qu'avec Monsieur Bruno Lemer dit
qu'il est de droite je pense ce sont de
bons ministres tous les deux qui vent
une politique que je soutiens et c'est
ça qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui quelle
lecture faites-vous de la durée que cela
prend on sent que c'est quand même un
petit peu compliqué bon il se br aussi
que bien sûr la relaxe de François
Baayou de lundi est en train de changer
la donne et attise les les appétit en
tout cas pour que les uns et les autres
soient représentés au sein de ce nouveau
gouvernement deux choses d'abord mon
collègue François patria dit que ça lui
est égal de travailler avec des
ministres de gauche ou de droite bien
sûr que les hommes et les femmes peuvent
être de grande qualité quel que soit
leur bord politique pour autant quand on
alterne gauche et droite comme on l'a vu
par exemple sur la culture j'en parlais
à l'instant finalement on fait du
surplace ça ça me gne davantage par le
Pass des alternan pour pour le reste
pour le reste moi je constate comme
beaucoup de Français que nous n'avons il
manque la moitié du gouvernement depuis
près d'un mois et finalement le pays
c'est terrible ne tourne ni mieux ni
moins bien je crois que ça interpelle et
qu'effectivement gens de remettre pays
en ordre de marche oui c'est vrai la
Belgique ça a été très très long est-ce
que Amélie oua Castera peut rester en en
poste Thomas deus puisque ça fait aussi
partie bien sûr de l'équation
c'est-à-dire qu'après un mois de
gouvernement on est déjà sur un
remanement dans le remanement donc ça ça
c'est c'est un peu compliqué non mais
celles et ceux qui doivent trouver le
temps long ce sont les ministres en
place là qui sont quand même sur des
portefeuilles très très larges et qui
commencent à mon avis un peu à attirer
la langue en terme de des de de d'effort
à faire euh par contre le reste de la
société j'ai pas l'impression que ça
soit un ranimement qui passionne les
foules on n'est pas sur un changement de
ligne on n'est pas sur la suite d'un
d'un virage politique qui aurait pu
avoir lieu après des élections donc on
est est vraiment sur un changement de
casting et on a l'impression qu'il y a
plus grand monde qui veut monter à bord
du navire et donc c'est devient de plus
en plus compliqué d'avoir un banc qui
veillent bien monter à bord de ce
gouvernement de ressources humaines oui
après savoir qui sera le prochain
ministre qui va casser la loi SRU ou le
modèle social français ou qui s'en
foutra toujours autant de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité franchement ça
passionne pas grand monde votre votre
commentaire Laurence rosignol sur cette
situation effectivement qui n'en finit
pas de durer et puis quand même aussi
bien sûr la question de l'éducation
nationale ù et bien Gabriel ATA avait
bien dit c'est la c'est la la mère des
batailles que c'était le le sujet sans
doute le plus important aujourd'hui et
où on voit une ministre qui est en très
grande difficulté ah bah pour ce qui est
de la ministre d'éducation nationale je
pense qu'elle ne peut pas rester à son
poste voilà c'est pas peut-être elle en
est désolée peut-être tout le monde en
est désolé mais enfin elle n'est pas
compatible aujourd'hui avec les défis
qui attend d'éducationtionale fragilisé
elle ne peut plus parler avec les
syndicat pas de crédibilité et surtout
elle a pas de crédibilité sur l'école
publique voilà alors maintenant je sais
bien que ça doit être compliqué de
former un gouvernement parce qu'avant il
fallait vérifier la Haute Autorité de la
transparence sa vie publique faut
demander aux impôts si tout le monde a
bien payé ses impôts maintenant il faut
demander probablement où sont inscrits
les enfants à l'école donc je reconnais
que ça devient long c'est de plus en
plus difficile hein t les critères et de
C toutes les moi je moi en fait ça j'ai
pas de commentaire à faire sur cette
affaire de gouvernement ce qui
m'inttéresse et la politique qu'il vont
mener et contrairement peut-être à
certains de nos collègues je crois pas
que la compétence so l'exclusif critère
parce que un gouvernement il a besoin de
gens compétents mais il faut pas croire
que les gens compétents n'ont pas
d'idéologie ils ont une idéologie et
donc ce gouvernement est profondément
marqué libéral le message du président
de la République puis du Premier
ministre c'est plus de dérégulation haut
et plus de règles en bas mais je
voudrais poser une question à ce
gouvernement penseent-t-il vraiment
qu'on peut rétablir l'ordre républicain
dans le désordre libéral or c'est le
désordre libéral qu'on nous promet pour
les derniers étages pour le top
management comme on dit dans les entre
reprise et c'est l'ordre républicain en
dessous ce qui fragilise terriblement la
capacité justement à rétablir l'ordre
républicain ce sera ma conclusion le
gouvernement les ministres on va moi
j'ai quelques années derrière moi j'en
ai déjà vu et attendu des gouvernements
et celui-là je suis très à l'aise parce
que je dis tout de suite ce gouvernement
cherche surtout à recruter des gens de
droite François patria ouais bon on veut
parler du fond bien sûr mais je ne
résiste pas quandme à vous poser la
question amilieou ca peut-elle rester en
poste moi je ne participe jamais à les
fa de meut tous ces gens qui dans parce
qu'ils ont trouvé une victime ça en
disant elle doit partir elle doit partir
partir je participe pas à ça c'est le
choix du Premier ministre et du
président de la République je le
respecte bon vous en perdez votre micro
on va vous réinstaller ça mais donc du
coup en attendant on va quand même
s'intéresser aussi à cette journée
d'hommage hommage aux victimes
françaises de l'attaque du 7 octobre
rendu aux Invalides ce midi regardez et
bien comment ça s'est passé Adrien
pin dans la cour d'honneur des inval 42
portraits desfil ce des Français tués
par le Hamas le 7 octobre les familles
de victimes assistent à la cérémonie
face à elle Emmanuel Macron appelle à
poursuivre la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme 4 mois jour pour jour
après l'attaque le Hamas lança par
surprise l'attaque massive et
odieuse le plus grand massacre
antisémite de notre siècle leur vie
mérite sans relâche de nous battre
contre les idées de haine de ne rien
céder à un an smitisme rampant désinhibé
ici comme là-bas dans le public trois
chaises vides en symbole des otages
français toujours disparu le chef de
l'État insiste sur sa détermination à
obtenir leur libération il demande
toutefois d'éviter une escalade du
conflit leur destins ne sont pas les
seuls que le déchirement du Moyen-Orient
continue de broyer dans cette tornade de
souffrance qu'est la
guerre et toutes les vies se valent
inestimables aux yeux de la France
jamais en nous nous nous ne laisserons
prospérer l'esprit de revanche après son
discours le président a échangé avec les
familles des victimes du 7 octobre
plusieurs sont venus spécialement depuis
Israël des représentants de l'ensemble
de la classe politique étaient aux
Invalides dont des responsables de la
France insoumise une présence décriée
par une partie des familles de victimes
le député Emer Caron a notamment été hué
à son
arrivée l'Élysée prévoit un hommage pour
les victimes françaises des
bombardements à Gaza la date n'a pas
encore été
pour et une nouvelle réaction politique
au micro d'Alexandre poussarsal des
conférence celle de la présidente du
groupe communiste au Sénat celle de
Cécile cuckerman Cécile cuckerman vous
étiez présente à cet hommage national
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti à ce
moment-là tout d'abord je crois et sans
surprise beaucoup d'émotions beaucoup de
tristesse pour ces femmes ces hommes qui
ont perdu leur vie dans des conditions
dramatique qui sont celles de l'attaque
terroriste dans les conditions
maintenant que que nous connaissons euh
et donc je crois en même temps un bel
hommage en tout cas que N notre pays se
devait de rendre à ceux qui ontt été
sauvagement exécuté le 7 octobre dernier
le président de la République l'a dit
toutes les vies se valent c'est une
manière aussi de penser aux victimes à
Gaza et un hommage pour les victimes
françaises à Gaza est aussi nécessaire
oui mais je je crois que il faut cesser
d'opposer les uns aux autres et encore
plus les morts entre eux donc je pense
que avec ses mot le président de la
République en tout cas a tenu un
discours juste sur ce sujet un discours
effectivement qui rappelle que le pire
dans la guerre ce sont les morts et des
vies humaines de civils qui n'ont rien
demandé et qui et qui meurent
quotidiennement les pires dans un acte
de barbarie et de terrorisme tel que
celui perpétré par le Hamas le 7 octobre
dernier ce sont ces jeunes ces ces ces
vieux ces ces gens de ces enfants qui
alors qu'il n'aspirait qu'à vivre et
qu'à vivre heureux à faire la fête pour
une grande partie d'entre eux d'ailleurs
cette nuit-là se sont retrouver sans vie
parce que répondant à une folie humaine
qui est celle de l'acte terrorisme
commis par le Hamas les familles des
victimes de cette attaque du 7 octobre
ont dénoncé la présence d'élus insoumis
à cet hommage national à cause de leur
ambigué autour de cette attaque
terroriste est-ce que les insoumis
avaient leur place écoutez moi je je
n'ai pas à commenter euh le choix des
autres formations politiques donc ça il
leur appartient euh de s'en exprimer euh
en tout cas je sais au combien pour ma
famille politique nous avions toute
notre place j'y étais avec Yann brossa
sénateur de Paris qui était également
associé puis avec mes collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale notamment André
chassigne et Fabien roussal et je crois
que nous y étions nous devions d'y être
euh je n'oseraai dire que nous nous
satisfaisions d'y être parce que nous
aurions préféré que il n'y ait pas ses
morts et que nous n'en soyons pas là
aujourd'hui mais mais je crois que
c'était un hommage de la nation à nos
concitoyens qui ont Péré dans les
conditions que nous connaissons sur la
guerre actuelle entre Israël et le Hamas
est-ce que la France est assez ferme
pour obtenir un cess le feu notamment
assez ferme vis-à-vis du gouvernement
israélien non mais je crois que que que
la France et que notre gouvernement
souffre aujourd'hui d'un essoufflement
de de sa voix diplomatique qui a été la
la sienne d'ailleurs dans les décennies
précédentes et qu' nous fut là la
retrouver parce que finalement le bilan
de cette journée c'est que plus que
jamais nous avons besoin de paix et sans
mauvais je de mot d'un combat pour la
paix la paix est un acte politique la
paix n'est pas un idéal la paix est un
acte politique qui vise à dire que nous
devons trouver d'autres relations que
celles de conflits meurtriers dont sont
victimes les populations civiles et
surtout de laquelle il ne sort aucun
progrès social donc oui la paix est un
acte politique et le président de la
République le Premier ministre
l'ensemble des élus que nous sommes nous
devons agir dans ce sens agir dans ce
sens pour reconstruire les bases d'un
ProcheOrient d'abord en paix mais parce
que les Israéliens en ont besoin pour
vivre en paix parce que les Palestiniens
en ont besoin pour vivre en paix et que
plus largement l'ensemble du monde en a
besoin pour vivre en paix parce que
sinon nous aurons demain malheureusement
des actes qui
viendront qui seront commis dans nos
territoires en représaille donc nous
avons besoin toutes et tous de la paix
pour pouvoir continuer de bien vivre
dans notre pays et dans le monde entier
merci beaucoup à CÉC cuerman pour votre
réaction merci merci beaucoup Alexandre
pour cette nouvelle réaction tout à
l'heure le président de la République a
placé son discours sous le signe de la
lutte contre
l'antisémitisme c'était essentiel de le
de le rappeler dans cette dans ce moment
4 mois après l'attaque terroriste du 7
octobre Laurence Garnier bien sûr le
président de la République a eu des mots
forts qui sont je pense à la hauteur de
du drame terrible qu'ont connu ses
victimes qui ont connu leur famille
euh donc je crois que c'était essentiel
d'avoir cette cérémonie aujourd'hui
d'hommage à à ces 42 victimes euh de de
l'attaque terroriste et il faut rappeler
de l'attaque de cette organisation
terroriste qui est le Hamas maintenant
l'antisémitisme ne va pas s'arrêter pour
autant en France il a explosé aussi
depuis l'attaque du Hamas le 7 octobre
dernier moi je je souhaite véritablement
que la France soit à la hauteur de ce
combat contre
l'antisémitisme qu'on espérait être
derrière nous et qui malheureusement
aujourd'hui est devant nous on l'a vu
aussi avec un certain nombre de
responsables politiques peut-on nous
appeler responsable mais en tout cas
d'élus politiques de la nation qui ont
refusé de condamner les attaques et de
nommer les choses en expliquant que le
Hamas était une organisation terroriste
et je crois que ça c'est grave
effectivement vous parlez de de la
France insoumise et notamment de de
Daniel obono qui avait même parlé de de
résistance en parlant euh du Hamas
qu'est-ce que vous inspire la polémique
qui a quand même aussi marqué cet
hommage avec notamment certaines
familles certains responsables de la
communauté juive qui euh et bien
désirait que la France insoumiste ne
soit pas présente lors de lors de cet
hommage he et je et je lis les mots de
cette lettre du collectif no silence
entre indécence absence de respect
relativisme et négationnisme la France
insoumise et ses porte-paroles se
sont-il illustré par des propos
gravissimes depuis le progromme du 7
octobre oui ben je je le rejoins tout à
fait euh
institutionnellement ils sont élus de la
nation ils ont été élus par des Français
qui ont souhaité que ce soit ces
personnes-là de ces députés de la France
insoumise qui les représente au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale
institutionnellement ils sont élus de la
nation on ne peut rien dire de plus par
contre politiquement je crois
qu'effectivement leur refus de nommer
les choses de condamner clairement les
attaques terroristes du Hamas et la la
l'indélicatesse qui qui frise
l'indesscence par rapport à ces familles
qui ne souhaitaent pas leur présence
aurait voulu effectivement par par
dessence et par respect pour les
familles qu'il ne soient pas présents
aujourd'hui lence signale est-ce que ce
n'est pas dommage que la polémique est
ainsi entaché à un événement comme cet
hommage et en même temps bon ben voilà
ce sont des questions qui qui se posait
qu'il fallait poser que les familles on
ont posé donc on ne peut pas non plus
les ber lmique que vous évoquez elle est
déplorable depuis le 7 octobre c'est
c'est depuis le 7 octobre que nous avons
un problème avec un certain nombre de
déclarations qui sont faites
effectivement par des responsables de la
France insoumise euh je voudrais quand
même dire que nous avons aussi quand
même encore un problème avec le
rassemblement national don qui ne fera
pas oublier dans cette affaire qu'il est
l'héritier d'un parti l'héritier et
l'héritière d'un parti et d'un dirigeant
qui ont été qui est marqué par
l'antisémitisme Jean Le Pen voilà
Jean-Marie Le Pen il faut quand même pas
pas pas non plus passer ça sous silence
et que Front national la rassemble
nationale aujourd'hui organisation
extrême droite adore Israël quand Israël
est dirigé par l'extrême droite il y a
aussi des liens politiques moi pour en
ce qui me concerne je trouve que quand
même notre pays peut être fier de lui
dans cette affaire nous sommes le seul
pays qui a une immense
manifestation prier contre le premier
pays qui a une grande manifestation
contre l'antisémitisme il se passe des
chos très importante aussi en Allemagne
euh bien entendu et positive en
Allemagne n premier nous l'hommage rendu
par le Président de la République ce
matin aux franco-israéliens et aux
Français victimes du massacre du 7
octobre nous place là encore comme un
pays très engagé dans la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme mais aussi dans le
rassemblement de la de notre de notre
communauté nationale c'est ça qui est
important aujourd'hui et je crois que le
discours du président était un beau
discours ce qui a été fait ce matin est
un beau moment et on dit souvent euh du
mal de nous-mêmes on est on n'est pas
toujours positif quand on parle de
nous-même là on peut être fier dans
cette dans ce moment-là de la manière
dont la France se comporte se comporte
bien et je dois dire très franchement on
n'a pas eu en France les manifestations
qu'on a vu dans des pays anglo-saxons
avec 300000 personnes qui manifestaient
pour une Palestine euh de la de de du
Jourdain euh à la mer où euh voilà on n'
pas eu ça en France et ça c'est
intéressant parce que que c'est c'est le
résultat mais je vais vous le dire fait
des années qu'on nous raconte oui la
laïité à la française c'est pas bien
c'est bien mieux le multiculturalisme le
communautarisme regardez les
Anglo-Saxons comme ils sont formidables
voilà et la laïité la française elle est
c'est pas bien c'est pas et ben écoutez
je trouve que la laïcité à la française
c'est dans ces moments-l je m'étais fait
la même réflexion en 2015 après les
attentats où je trouvais que les peuple
français s'était très bien comporté la
laïcité à la française elle produit ce
pays qui est caplable à à la fois de
dire que les il faut que il faut que les
morts s'arrêtent à Gaza il faut que les
les civils cessent de de périr sous les
bombes il faut une solution politique
voilà et c'est pas dissociable de la
question de deux états avec des
frontières sûres et j'entends beaucoup
en ce moment on dire oui non mais c'est
plus possible les deux états faut passer
à autre chose les un dis les ind disent
qu'il faut qu'Israël s'installe partout
les autres disent qu'il faut un État
binational tout ça n'a pas de sens il
faut pas lâcher parce que notre voix est
importante sur la solution politique
c'est deux états avec des frontières
sûres François patria voilà un sujet
d'unanimité sur le plateau c'est assez
rare quand même pour être souligné je
remercie mes collègues et notamment
laurentignol d'un des propos d'union
qu'il a tenu de responsabilité que je
partage ce moment a été un moment
suspendu d'une grande humanité d'une
France forte qui lutte aujourd'hui
contre l'antisémitisme avec beaucoup de
véhé avec ses valeurs laïques telles
qu'elles ont été évoquées ça a été un
moment d'émotion et de dignité je ne
rentre entre pas dans la polémique qui a
été introduite sur la présence ou pas je
prouve qu'il y a une question de dcence
à participer à ce genre de manifestation
quand on a tenu les propos qu'on a tenu
mais je veux pas polémiquer sur le sujet
je crois que le
président non mais pas
polémiquer ils arrêtent de le sentir
eux-même il y a une part de provocation
qui vaut pour l'extrême de gauche et
comme l'extrême droite pour les deux ça
a été rappelé à l'instant je pense que
les propos du chef de l'État on rappeler
que c'est en France que la première
grande hommage rendu pays qui rend
homage aujourd'hui à ce ceux qui on tous
les massacres à toutes les personnes qui
ont été massacré à toutes les familles
dans le deil sans oublier les otages
n'oublions pas ici aujourd'hui les
otages j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
les familles d'otage
Isra en israë tris chev très symbolique
j'ai l'occasion de rencontrer les
familles d'otage je à combien il nous
ont dit à tous pensez à nous pensez aux
étages ne nous oubliez pas dans vos
chaînes de télévision quelle qu'elle
soit aujourd'hui montrer la difficulté
aujourd'hui qu' les familles le drame
qu'ell connaissent de le faire avec
beaucoup d'émotion un moment d'émotion
dignité que comm le chef de l'État c'est
concl un moment d'unité de la nation je
trouve que ces moments-là il faut les
sublimer un peu Thomas Dosu vous
retrouvez dans cette unité de de la
nation oui oui je partage partage cétait
important que le le chef de l'État
marque l'unité des 68 millions de
Français en solidarité avec les
compatriotes qui sont décédés lors de ce
massacre il a rappelé que c'était le
plus grand massacre antisémite du 21e
siècle il raison de le dire et je pense
que c'était oui un moment très digne et
c'était important qu'on soit aussi une
nation assemblé vous dites de prendre
aussi toute la la la part sur le le
destin des des otages je pense que là en
revanche la la la voix de la France est
encore trop faible pour faire stopper
ces bombardements qui sur Gaza qui
prennent peu en compte à mon avis la vie
des otages et on voit bien que les
familles d'otagees y compris en Israël
se plaignent de cette stratégie
militaire à Gaza et je pense que la voix
de la France a perdu de sa force et
qu'aujourd'hui elle doit reprendre un
peu de du muscle pour trouver la
solution politique appeler au cesser le
feu immédiat et à la fin du siège l'une
des questions qui se pose aussi
aujourd'hui c'est quit de l'hommage aux
victimes françaises dans le siège de
Gaza et bien ce matin le président du
Consistoire de Paris Joël Mergy a estimé
sur Public Sénat qu' était pas question
de faire un parallélisme écoutez il'est
pas question pour nous
aujourd'hui de mettre sur le même plan
les victimes intentionnelles d'un plan
barbare
porome assassinat dont je viens de
parler avec tout ce qu'on sait
d'intention de préparation de de de de
de haine qui s'est déchaîné avec les
victimes collatérales d'une
guerre Laurence Garnier pas question de
faire un parallélisme enfin une vie à
Gaza en vaut une en Israël c'est quand
même important aussi de le rappeler bien
sûr bien sûr un homme est un homme un
bébé est un bébé et qu'il soit israélien
ou ou de la bande de gaz
un un mort est toujours terrible donc au
niveau de l'humanité nous partageons la
même humanité et ça n'est même pas un
sujet j'ai envie de dire ça ne doit
surtout pas être un sujet euh en
revanche je crois qu'au niveau politique
effectivement on peut pas faire de
parallélisme la situation est différente
il faut nommer les choses une attaque
terroriste du Hamas qui a toucher 1200
ou presque 1200 israéliens qui sont
décédés le 7 octobre tous les otages on
le rappelait à l'instant ça n'est pas la
même chose qu'une guerre de ripost mené
par un État démocratique Israël et pour
autant ça n'enlève rien à l'horreur de
la guerre que je crois ici n nous nous
nous constatons tous et et à l'horreur
de ces familles de ces hommes de ces
femmes de ces enfants qui décèdent sous
les bombes à Gaza le mot de la fin
Thomas dossieux alors qu'effectivement
on attend aussi ce temps mémoriel que
l'Élysée annonce pour les victimes de
Gaza oui moi j'entends parler de
victimes collatéral moi je ne partage
pas ce terme quand on bombarde une zone
aussi densément peuplée que Gaza quand
on utilise des armes explosives dans des
villes aussi peuplées il n'y a pas de
victime collatéral toutes les victimes
sont ciblées on sait on sait on connaît
les conséquences de ces bombardements et
donc même si on ne fait pas de
parallélisme entre les deux il faut
aussi savoir qualifier ce qui se passe à
Gaza de CRIM de guerre et je pense que
aujourd'hui on a besoin que la justice
internationale se penche sur ce qui s'y
passe et on a